hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel if you're here to learn
java then you're at the right place this
java fill course will include all the
major fundamentals based on java
programming language
so before diving into that i would like
to let you know guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies if you
are a technique in continuous hand for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and hit that bell icon
so that you never miss an update from us
so without further ado let's begin with
the agenda for today's discussion so at
first we will go through a brief
introduction of java followed by that
we'll learn the installation of java in
your local system next we'll learn what
exactly is a java development kit
followed by that we'll install
eclipse ide into your local system then
we will go through some major
fundamentals of java then we have the
object oriented programming concepts in
java and inside that we will learn the
java abstraction java encapsulation
java inheritance java polymorphism so
once we are done with the object
oriented programming we will dive into
the next segment where we will learn the
data structures or otherwise called as
java collections then followed by the
java collections we have the exception
handling in java followed by exception
handling we will dive into java database
connectivity once we are done with the
java database connectivity we will enter
the java servlets once we are finished
with the java servlets we will have the
java application programming interface
then we have the java enterprise edition
tutorial followed by that we have the
junit tutorial and finally to make
things better we will also go through
some most frequently asked java
interview questions
now i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now escalating over to our
training experts
in today's era the internet and
smartphones have become an integral part
of our lives we use our phones for
almost all of our day-to-day tasks
earlier we used to shop at malls queue
up in front of banks and make our travel
bookings at travel agencies but now we
can do all this in the comfort of our
homes using smartphones all of this is
possible because of a high-level
programming language called java hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class-based object-oriented programming
language java
java is an object-oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a high
level language that is easy to read and
understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems apart from
these java is also used to develop
software for devices it is used not only
in computers and mobiles but even in
electronic devices like televisions
washing machines air conditioners and so
on online forms banking and shopping are
possible because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991.
he had a single moto while creating the
language it was right once run anywhere
this meant that the code would have to
be written only once but it could be
used anywhere they named this language
oak because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995.
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java.util
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an object oriented programming
language based on c and c plus however
it is improved and simplified to solve
the errors in programming java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the java
interpreter the whole java code is run
on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task
methods in java are the same we can have
methods to add two numbers or email a
person or to convert kilometers to
meters a group of methods make a class
classes are used to organize code just
like how fruits vegetables and clinical
products are divided into different
sections in a supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling
this makes java very unique the most
popular feature of java is that it is
platform independent here compilation
happens in byte code and because of this
java can run on any machine it is a very
secure language as it contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data the next
feature is inheritance as the name
suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ in
this video we'll be telling you how you
can install java and showing you a very
simple java program so let's get started
so first off let's go to google and
search for java here let's go to this
link and here you have a number of
different options now first off we have
java se 13.01 which is the latest
release but we're going to go for java
sc8 which is the more commonly used one
which is used by most people around the
world so this is what we are going to
use so we select this and here we go
down a bit so to proceed we need to
accept the license agreement we've
accepted the license so now we can
download the software so we have two
options to choose from windows x64 or
x86 now if you have a windows 10
operating system it's highly likely that
you have a 64 bit operating system so
you can select this option now if you do
have a 32-bit operating system which is
probably like windows 7 you can select
the x86 option as well so now let's
click on this so you need to log in and
all that we've already finished and
we've have the download already so let's
get
it so now this dialog box will pop up
now we'll go to the next option here
we'll accept them the way they are
and now we'll wait for it to install
so now we need to select the destination
where you want the install to happen so
now this is installed in the program
files we select this if you want to
change it you can go to this option here
we don't want to change it we'll just go
from here to next and now we wait for
the installation to complete
so now the installation is complete now
we don't need to look at any other next
steps we'll just stop and go to close so
now we need to provide an environment
variable so what is that used for now if
you have files or applications that have
the java extension these help tell the
computer that we need to run it using
the java program so now let's create an
environment variable go to start go to
control panel and then we go to system
and then this pops up now before we
select the environment variables we need
to find the path where we install java
so i installed it in c drive here so
let's go there in c program files java
and here we have jdk and gre first we
select the jdk or the java development
kit we select it and go into bin where
all these files are present and where
the java file is present as well so now
we're going to copy this path now let's
go back to environment variables and
select path from here which is right
here now at the end of this we'll add a
semicolon and paste the path now
similarly we'll do the same thing for
jre so now we're going to do the same
thing with gre here which is the java
run environment so we'll go back select
gre go into bin and select the path from
here we add another semicolon and paste
the path we press ok and it's done press
ok here as well and now we're done now
to check whether java has been installed
in your system we need to go to the
command prompt here we'll type the term
java c which refers to the java compiler
now the output will show a number of
different options you can choose from
this is an indication that java has been
successfully installed in your system if
the installation wasn't successful the
statement like java c is not recognized
as an internal or external command
operable program or batch file will be
shown to you so now that we've set up an
environment of java in our computer
let's see how we can code java for this
we'll need to use an ide on which we can
run the java code we will be using
eclipse ide now there are several other
ides like intellij netbeans doctor java
and so on first off we need to install
eclipse so let's go to google and search
for eclipse ide go here download select
this option and now we'll just click on
download so i've already downloaded the
exe file so let's just go there so then
this shows up so here you have a number
of different options eclipse can be used
for a number of different languages like
enterprise java c c plus plus javascript
php and so on so we need it for java
developers so we click this so this has
already determined where exactly the
java file is which you can see here it
shows the installation folder here and
now all we need to do is install we need
to accept the terms and conditions which
we'll just go through quickly except now
and now the installation has started we
remember accepted licenses accept it
this shows up you can select remember
accepted certificates select these
except selected and there you go the
installation is complete now let's
select launch now we need to set up the
eclipse ids workspace which you can
change if you want i'm just going to
keep it at this now we select launch and
here you go here is the eclipse ide now
let's have a look at how we can create a
very simple java program so first we'll
close the welcome tab and here we have
the package explorer now in case the
package explorer isn't shown for you
initially you can go to windows you can
go to show view and select on package
explorer so now let's have a look at how
we can create the program first we go to
file click on new and select java
project so here you need to input the
project's name i'm calling it proj1
press next and here you see the src file
or the source file where all the source
code is located you press finish and
it's done if you click on this you can
also see the source file now we need to
click on source right click press new
and create a new class here you need to
name your class i'm calling it my class
and finish now within this we need to
create the main function which is public
static
void
main here we'll write a simple statement
and now let's see if the program runs
now we select the class on the basis of
which we'll be running the code and
there you go we have an output so this
is the continuation of the statement in
726 for this video we will be using
eclipse as well as intellij as these are
one of the most common and popular ides
there are also other ideas available
like netbeans doctor java bluejay and so
on now continue to this part the one on
screen so now that we're done with this
let's have a look at how we can run a
similarly simple program on intellij
which is another ide now we'll need to
install it as well so let's go to google
and search for intellij let's go here
click on download and here you have two
options which is the ultimate and the
community now the community version is
free but has limitations as you can see
here there are certain limitations for
the open source version however we're
going to take this free version and
download it now i've already downloaded
it so we'll cancel this and i'm going to
run this one we'll go to next select
this location you can change it if you
want by going to browse here go next if
you want you can select any of these
options i'm going to select these
associations because this basically
means intellij also supports these
particular extensions you select the
desktop shortcut go to next and install
now we'll be running intellij will not
send user statistics there you go the
ide is now open now we'll click on
create new project we select java and
from here you can also select two of
your additional frameworks if you want
here you should also make sure that this
option is selected we have java sc 1.8
now if this isn't selected you can drop
down and select this option here you can
press next now you need to make sure
this box is checked and now we're going
to create a command line application and
we are going to create a command line
application let's press next we need to
select a project name project one and
finish so now we're going to create a
very simple program how you can add two
numbers so let's get started so now
we're going to initialize the first
variable assign it with the value of 10
then for the second one assign it with
the value of 20. now we're going to
write the code to add the two numbers
some equal to first
plus second now that we're done with
that let's print the output
and there we go we're done now let's run
this code and there we go program is
running successfully so this is how you
code java in eclipse and intellij in
this video we are going to talk about
what is java
what is java development kit or jdk the
components of jdk
how do jre jvm and jdk work together
then the latest version of jdk
we'll also see what java lambda
expression means and the key features of
jdk9
so what is java
it is a fast reliable and secure
programming language that can be used in
several websites and applications
it can be used to create applications in
a single computer or one that could be
distributed across several servers and
clients
java can be used in several scenarios
independent of the system that it is
used on
so let's look into what java development
kit means
all the java applications and applets
are developed using the java development
kit that is jdk
now the jdk consists of the java runtime
environment
an interpreter
a compiler
an archiver
and a document generator and a few more
tools that go into developing a java
program
so now let us have a look at the
components of jdk
java runtime environment jre primarily
is a part of jdk and it can also be
termed as java rte
the jdk provides the minimal amount of
requirements needed to write and compile
a java program
jre consists of the jvm supporting files
and the core classes
the jvm is key to both jdk and the jre
because it is embedded into them now
whichever java program is being run the
jvm is that component of java that
executes a program line by line thus
giving itself the work of an interpreter
we are now in a position to deep dive
into the process with which jdk jre and
jvm work
let's take a source file and save it
with the extension dot java
this file is compiled and converted into
a set of byte code which changes the
file extension into dot class
this is done specifically by the jdk
now here are the steps that follow class
loader
it makes sure that all the necessary
classes are loaded in the time of the
execution of a program
next bytecode verifier that is jvm
the bytecode verifier checks the code
for errors or irregularities based on
access rights on objects or
implementation of pointers
it makes sure that the code fulfills the
specifications of jbm and does not break
the system integrity and finally
interpreter which is jvm
now while running the program the
interpreter loads checks and runs the
code the implementation is made by the
jre which is the final process
the latest release is jdk 9 and it was
released in october 2017
but it was in jdk8 that a new feature
called the java lambda expression was
introduced that changed the face of java
now java lambda expression is a kind of
function which does not need any class
to be created
it has been included in the latest
version of jdk as it provides a clear
concise way to pass functions around
this also replaces earlier bulky
anonymous classes and reduces code
verbosity that is the length of the code
the syntax for the lambda expression is
this
argument list
arrow token body
now the syntax consists of three
components which are
argument list
this can be empty or non-empty
next the arrow token now this is used to
link argument to body and finally body
this contains the statement that works
with the function
let us now just see an example
of using lambda expression and
contrasting it with how code would have
been written with anonymous classes
this is the old method
and this is the new method with lambda
expression
just have a look at how lambda
expression syntax has been used over
here the jdk 9 has been released
recently and it seems promising with
respect to new features and abilities
here are some of the
features the first one is java platform
module system
this module allows strong encapsulation
and declare explicit dependencies
next
j shell
with the help of j shell one can
directly start writing the code on the
console and execute them
improve javadoc
javadocs have got the search right in
the api documentation and as an added
bonus the output is also compliant to
html5
next stream api
the stream api also introduced in java 8
allows programmers to easily parallelize
code for improved concurrency and
introduces functional programming
abilities to the language the stream api
in conjunction with lambda expressions
also comes in handy while iterating
filtering and extracting large amount of
data
the release of multi-chart makes it
possible for codes to be run on the
newer versions of jdk to be released
welcome to this video on how to install
eclipse ide on your windows 10 operating
system now an ide is an integrated
development environment on this computer
programmers can perform software
development now eclipse is one of
several in the market like intellij
bluej dr java and so on now to install
eclipse first you need to install java
this is because if you try to run the
eclipse installer this shows up the
shows that you do need java before you
can install eclipse on your operating
system so first let's go and download
java now let's search for java install
and then go to this link now here we
have the latest version which is version
13. we're not going to pick that one up
we're going to go to version 8. now
we're choosing version 8 because this is
one of the most commonly used versions
of java so let's select this so we'll go
down all the way here and here we can
see two options the 64 bit and the 86
bit so this basically represents the
32-bit operating system so if you do
have one you can select this option
since we have a 64-bit operating system
i'm going to select this but before the
installation you need to accept license
agreement and select this now i've
already logged in so i'm just going to
install now select this go downloads
click on this and then this shows up
we'll go to next we'll go to next and
let the install complete
so here we have another pop-up so if you
want to change the destination folder
you can select this option this is fine
with me so i'm going to go with next
that's it we'll let the installation
complete now so there you go the
installation is now complete so if you
want to look at tutorials or
documentation you can go to the next
steps i don't want to so let's close and
go back now just because we've installed
java we can't exactly run it yet for
that we need environment variables now
environment variables help the computer
understand that it needs to run java
when it sees a dot java file for that
let's go to the control panel
let's go to system and then let's go
here
and select advanced system settings and
then this shows up now before we can set
the environment variables we'll need the
path to where java is installed so let's
go to file explorer let's click c drive
let's go to program files so this is
where i install java let's go to java
first let's go to jdk and bin now let's
go back here click on environment
variables select a path here go back
let's copy that
and press on new and paste this now
likewise let's go back go to jre which
is the java runtime environment and jdk
which is the java development kit click
on this go to bin and select this path
go back go to path
select new and paste this as well and
there you go the environment variables
are now set let's click on ok and that's
done now let's install eclipse let's go
back again and search for eclipse
in here select this option click on
download select 64-bit so and this shows
up so i've already downloaded it so we
can directly go there i'm going to click
on this now so now we have the installer
show up so here you can choose from a
number of different options like c c
plus plus php and so on so you want this
one we click on this and here we can
just install we'll accept and there you
go the installation is going on right
now we'll remember accepted licenses
except this you need to accept these
certificates
except selected and there you go we're
complete let's launch so now we need to
set up a directory so i'm okay with this
so let's launch
and there you go here's the workspace so
let's run a very simple program now so
we'll close this and here you have the
package explorer let's open this up so
in case you can't access the package
explorer go to window click on show view
and select package explorer now first to
run a program you need to create a java
project click on this and let's name our
project let's go to next and here you
see src or source now this is where the
source code of your program is now we'll
just finish
and that's that now we go to source
right click new and create class now
let's create a class
class
one and finish and now we should be able
to run any program we want let's look at
the very simple code of writing hello
world so let's open the main function
there you go let's open a bracket here
let's print
and that's that now let's run the
program by clicking on this icon let's
select the class and there we go we have
an output this means the program is
running successfully let's begin with
the fundamentals so the first one in the
fundamentals is the data types so every
programming language has a data type so
what exactly is a data type so whatever
the input you provide in your program is
a data type for example if you provide
numbers so in that particular numbers we
have a different variety of numbers if
you are given just 1 2 3 so on without a
decimal number then that particular type
of input which is a number will be
considered as integer type if you
provide the same number with a decimal
point then that will be considered as
float and if you have the range greater
than float it will be considered as
double and so on so this is how we have
multiple data types in every programming
language so the most frequently used
data types in java programming languages
are as follows at first we have the byte
followed by that we have short end long
next float then double boolean and
finally care apart from this we also
have few other data types but these are
the most frequently used ones for all
the basic programmings so this is made
for beginners basically so you can take
a quick screenshot of this particular
slide so that you can have a quick
overview or reference to all the data
types in java programming language so i
hope you have taken a screenshot of this
now let's begin with the next concept so
in the next concept we have the keywords
and variables so all the programming
languages have variables and keywords so
variables are used to store the values
so for example consider that you wanted
to run some automatic operation on two
different values that is 5 and 10. so in
order to do so you might want to create
a variable which stores them for example
you wanted to store the value of 10 in a
certain variable a and the 5 in a
certain variable b so if you apply the
arithmetic operation that is a is equals
to a plus b
then the value of a which was previously
10 will be updated to 15 so here you can
see the value is varying and also it is
storing the result so this is why the
variables are used in a program in order
to store a value and this particular
term variable is used because the value
can change at any instance of time once
after a certain arithmetic or a logical
operation is performed on that
particular variable so similarly we have
keywords unlike variables keywords have
a special meaning no matter whatever you
try you cannot change the meaning of
that keyword for example consider main
so you cannot use the term main for
normal things because the part or the
term main is dedicated for a different
purpose so whenever you try to execute
your java program the control flow will
start executing the program right when
it reads the term main
so it has a special meaning similarly
you have other keywords such as end so
that is dedicated for integer type of
values and float for float type of
values that is a decimal values and byte
for byte care for character type data
string for string so every keyword or
every term with special meaning which is
predefined and cannot be changed is
called as a keyword now let's see the
most frequently used keywords in java
programming language so similar to the
previous one we have a table here so in
this particular table we have the most
frequently used keywords in java so you
can see we have boolean final byte
native and we have void switch so switch
is a conditional statement so we have if
it is also a conditional statement we
will go through this conditional
statements as we proceed in our tutorial
and you can also see the protected so
this term which is protected public so
this is basically the access modifier
even this particular keyword have
special meaning this public this
protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or the interpreter about the
accessibility of that particular data
member or data manipulating method so if
it is protected from your accessibility
or is it available for you it's provided
by these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming parts
don't worry about that and as you can
see we have implements extends so
extension this term comes in inheritance
so inheritance is one of the crucial
concepts of object-oriented programming
you can also see abstraction so this we
will be dealing in the next upcoming
part where we will understand the
object-oriented programming concepts
next we have interface return and so on
you can also see some keywords like
through so throw will come in exception
handling so we will also learn about
exception handling in the upcoming part
so these are the most frequently used
keywords in java so now we will move
ahead into our next concept so the next
concept is the operators in java so to
understand operators let's go through a
table so on my screen you can see a
table which has some arithmetic
operators which are most commonly used
that is the plus for addition minus the
subtraction similarly we have star
forward slash double plus double minus
so double plus and double minus say they
are increment and decrement operators
respectively as you can see we have a
plus plus here which means the post
increment so the first
value will be read after that the value
will be updated next we have the
pre-increment
the value will be incremented first then
the updated value will be stored so
that's that's how the increment and
decrement operators work so we have the
modulus over here so to understand the
operators that we use in java in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program so on my screen you can see a
program which is based on operators so
we are currently on the eclipse ide
don't worry about the ids and java etc
etc so i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a very detailed way about how to
install java into your local system and
how to install eclipse ide in your local
system and also how to create your first
project how to create your package how
to create a new class how to write your
program and how to run that how to see
the output and a complete overview of
the eclipse ide how that works so
everything will be linked in the
description box below you don't have to
worry about that so right now to save
time i have created the text document
which has all the programs that we will
be executing today so i will also drop a
link for that particular file so that
you can have complete access to that
file so that you can run the programs in
your personal pcs or laptops and also
understand the programs in a much better
way so now let's begin with the program
so this particular program is basically
designed for automatic operations so you
can see we have the operators that is
the addition subtraction multiplication
division modulus and exit so basically
we will be taking input from mu so the
input will be taken by the user that is
we are using scanner class here so
scanner class takes the input from user
and that particular input will be
compared here so we're using the switch
case here so if you provide the option
as one then edition operation will be
run similarly second force abstraction
third for multiplication fourth for
division fifth for modulus and sixth to
exit so this is how the loop or the
program works for automatic operations
now let's quickly run this program and
see the output so you can see the
program got successfully executed and we
have the console asking for the first
input let's provide some random number
now
let's provide the second number so there
you go we have our options over here now
let's choose uh division operation for
that we need to provide the number four
so there you go we have the result over
here which is 4. now the loop has
started once again now it's in the
starting stage again it's asking for
numbers now let's provide 25 and
5.
now let's choose some operation that is
addition so for that you need to provide
one so we have the result again that is
30.
now
let's again choose some number 10
5. so basically that's how the program
works so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now so now let's
quickly continue with our next topic now
to terminate this loop you can provide
the option number six so we have
terminated it so i hope you understood
how the program flow is running so if
you did not understand don't worry i
have linked the
document in the description box below
you can take the access of that
particular document and you can check
the program and run in your local system
and also you can make some modifications
to it as you can see we don't have a
default case over here i've just placed
the case one two six and
i'm seeing the default because you can
see that the options are from one to six
what if the user provides the number of
7 right so the program might crash over
here so for that purpose you can write
in another case that would be the
default case so the default case will
check if the number is anything above or
out of the range of one to six then it
should be providing you with an output
saying a wrong input has been given or
check your input or something similar so
that's how you can make some
modifications to it you're free to
modify the code as well don't worry
about that so now let's quickly begin
with our next concept so in the next
concept we have the conditional
statements so what are the conditional
statements or the control statements so
basically these are some
yeah these are conditions so what
happens is just imagine that you wanted
to do something or if you wanted to
drive a vehicle or if you wanted to
drive a bike so the condition you will
apply on your mind is if i know driving
then i will do it if not i'll not do it
so that's what you do right so basically
you apply a condition on your mind and
you do it if it is capable of doing or
if you are capable of doing it so in the
same way the conditional statements play
a major role in computer logic so before
writing a code or before you start your
program you provide the condition
perform this particular operation if the
provided condition is satisfied so
similarly you have these three
conditional statements in java which are
if else and nested if so we use these
conditional statements in java to
implement our logic so we will
understand the conditional statements
particularly if if else and necessitif
in a much more detailed way by
practically running some programs based
on these three types of conditional
statements so now you can see that we
are back on the eclipse right now so
this particular code segment is based on
the if condition i hope the program is
visible let's try to increase the font
size so i think it's better now so
basically we have an input so we have
the integer type of input that is num
and we have the number as minus 100 so
it is a negative number and after that
we have the if condition so this is
where the conditional statement is
provided so the condition is if the
number is greater than 0 if the provided
number is greater than 0 then the
control should enter the loop which is
this particular segment and execute the
statements present inside that
particular loop so here we have one
single statement that is a print
statement that says the number is
positive in case the condition fails
imagine that the condition fails then
what happens is that instead of entering
this particular code segment this
particular code segment the control will
skip and execute the next statement that
is another printf statement which we
have over here which says the if
condition is terminated control is
outside the condition block now since we
have provided a negative number the
second option should go ahead now let's
try to run this and see the output so
there you go as expected the program got
executed and we have only one statement
that is if condition is terminated
control is outside the block now let's
write otherwise let's just eliminate the
negative number and now check it again
there you go now you can see the program
got executed and now we have two print
statements you can see that the
condition here was true so the control
entered into the statement or the code
block and this particular statement got
executed successfully once the
statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do then the control will
automatically exit this particular
statement and it will enter into the
next statement which is another printf
statement and we have the same output
over there so this is how the single if
statement works so you can also modify
this with an else so that's the next
program that we are going to see we are
going to execute some similar kind of
example
for our next kind of conditional
statement that is if else so here only
we had one if condition so in case if
this particular condition fails then we
will be having another condition over
here which will be the else block so as
you can see we have another program so
this particular program is based on if
else condition so here you can see that
we have our first ifcondition which
states number should be greater than or
equals to 0. if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive else
else if this condition fails then what
you must do the control should avoid
entering this particular segment and it
should directly hit the next segment
where we have the else block which has
another statement which says the number
is negative so this is how the program
works so here we will be doing a little
modification over there instead of
taking an input which is previously
defined as it was in the previous
example where we had given minus 100
previously we are going to do it a
little differently this time we'll be
taking or reading the input directly
from the user so for that we are going
to use this scanner class so this is the
particular library that we will be using
so we have imported java.util.scanner
so this particular code segment will ask
you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
there you go the program was
successfully executed and now it is
asking for an input from the user now
let's try to provide a negative number
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that since we had given a negative
number the control did not enter this
particular code segment at all it
directly avoided to enter this code
segment and entered into the else block
and executed the statements present in
that particular else block which was a
simple print statement that had the
statement which read as the number is
negative now let's try to execute the
same program again and see what would be
the output so there you go now it's
asking for the input again now this time
let's provide a positive number so there
you go since we provided the number as a
positive number this condition was true
and this particular statement got
executed since one of the statements
executed there was no need for the else
block to be executed again so you can
see this particular code segment runs in
this way so once the condition is
checked so if the condition is true then
the true statement will be executed in
case if the conditions result is false
then the false statements will be
executed so you will be provided with
two options so one option for true
validity and another option for false
validity so this is how the if else
block works i hope you understood this
now with this let's continue with the
next type of conditional statement that
is the lcf ladder so on my screen you
can see there is a change of program we
have stepped into the next type of
conditional statement that is the lsf
ladder so basically everything will be
seen we will be provided with only one
condition so we will be checking the
validity of that particular condition so
if the provided condition is true then
the first one will be executed if it is
not then the second one will be executed
if the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed if the
first three failed in the fourth and if
all the four fails then we will have one
last else which will print the last
segment or statement so this is how the
lc flatter works so basically it's
completely similar to if else but the
only difference is instead of one else
block we have multiple else blocks
that's the only difference now let's
quickly execute this program and say the
output so basically we are going to take
an input from the user so we will be
entering one for noodles two for
milkshake three for fruits four for
coffee so something like that and if we
provide anything else then one two three
four then we will be having an else
statement which says it's an invalid
input so the flow of this particular
elsif statement is similar to the switch
statement having said that we will also
discuss something about switch statement
as well basically we'll try to execute a
program based on a switch statement and
we'll also understand the control flow
of that don't worry about it now let's
quickly execute this particular program
first so there you go the program got
successfully executed now it's asking
for an input
let's select noodles that's how it works
we have the output nodals so the choice
is equal to is equals to one so the
first one was true so it executed the
first code segment and everything else
got suspended because this was not
necessary to be executed because the
condition was true over here and
according to that only this particular
statement was supposed to be executed so
that's how it works now let's switch
into the next conditional statement
which is the switch so you can see that
we have a program on my screen which is
based on switch case
so you can see that there is some
similarity between this particular
program and the first program we dealt
with that is based on operators
so we also have the default code segment
over here so this was what i was talking
about you can add a default code segment
in that particular program which is a
operators program and do some
modifications so this is what the
suggestion i gave over there now
basically what happens in this
particular code segment is so we have
monday as the day one of a week tuesday
as the day two of the week and so on so
uh to select one particular day of a
week you need to provide an input so
it's based on one two three four and so
on to seven and if you provide anything
else than one two seven you will be
provided with an message which says
invalid input so now let's try to uh run
this program and see the output so there
you go the program got successfully
executed now let's select the weekend
day
so which would be something between six
and seven so six is saturday and seven
is sunday let's go with seven so there
you go sunday now let's try to execute
this program once again and give a wrong
input and see if it works or not let's
provide eight
there you go the program identified it
as a wrong input so it gave us a message
invalid input so that's the use of
default code segment in switch case so
you can implement this in that
operator's program and check out how it
works can be considered as a homework
though not a problem now this is how the
switch case works so with this let's
move ahead into the next concept in our
java tutorial for today so the next
segment is about the loops so what are
loops
so conditional statements are
some statements which get executed based
on a condition if the condition is true
if not then that particular condition
will not be executed loops are a little
different from conditional statements
how so basically you will be provided
with one single statement and you wanted
to execute that one single statement for
a particular number of times so in that
condition instead of writing the same
code segment for several number of times
you can just use a loop for example
consider that you wanted to print
numbers from 1 to 10. so the brute force
method or the simple or the first method
that fires to your mind is write that
print statement for 10 times that is
print 1 print 2 print 3 and so on to
print 10 but what if you had to print
100 numbers
okay doable you can write the same print
statement 400 times but what if you had
to print thousand numbers
imagine one billion can you do one
billion print statements no right so in
that scenario you can use loops so you
can just write one condition
repeat this particular print statement
for 1 billion times then the interpreter
or the compiler will take care of that
so that's the reason why we use loops in
java so basically we have three loops in
every programming language that is the
for loop while loop and do while loop so
a loop statement in java execute a set
of statements until a specific condition
is satisfied so here the one billion
example so here you will start from the
zeroth count so that will be the counter
variable which counts the number of
repetitions and followed by the counter
variable you will be having the
condition so you will be having the
count of variable i i is less than or
equal to the number 1 billion so until
that you have to print this particular
statement and followed by that you will
be having the increment or decrement
operator in this case you need to use
the increment operator for the first
time once the print is done you will
increment the value to 2 and the loop
will be iterated once again so this will
continue the loop will iterate itself
until 1 2 3 4 so on and until it reaches
1 billionth number so that's when the
condition fails i is greater than or
equal to 1 billion so that's when the
condition fails the condition was to be
i should be less than or equal to 1
billionth so when the number increments
above 1 billion then the condition fails
so the condition was the number should
be less than or equal to billion but the
number has exceeded the billion so
that's when the loop terminates and
executes the next statement after the
loop so i think this was a little clear
about the loop workflow now to
understand the loops in a much more
better way let's execute an example for
each one of these types of loops so we
have forum while open do while let's
execute the program for all of these
three so you can see that we have a
program on my screen so this particular
program is based on for loop so you can
see that the quote part highlighted on
my editor is the follow so you can see
int i is equals to 1 so this is the
counter variable so i is the counter
variable which stores a number from
where the count should begin so
sometimes you can choose zero sometimes
one or the number of your choice so here
i've chosen the number one so after the
initialization part we have the
condition part so remember the one
billionth example we discussed before so
here we have i should be less than or
equal to 10. so this particular loop
segment will run until the condition
that is i value should be less than or
equal to 10 is satisfied once it turns
false the control will exit the for loop
so that's how it's designed to work with
now followed by the condition we have
the pre-increment operator once the
condition is checked the control will
jump to the next statement that is the
pre-increment operator and it increments
the value of 1 to 2. so this is how the
loop works now let's try to execute this
program and see the output there you go
the program got successfully executed
and the output has been printed so
basically what was the statement to be
executed it was a printf statement
looped plus here the plus symbol works
as a concatenation operator here too now
in between the printf statements we have
the value of i so in the first place i
was equals to 1 once the pre-increment
was taken place the value of i will be
increased to 2 so there you go you can
see the number 2 over there now in the
second iteration we print the value
looped two times similarly in the third
iteration looped three times so that's
how it works until the last iteration
that is looped 10 times so once the
condition is checked here the control
will enter into the next part where the
pre-increment takes place so the
pre-increment increments the value of 10
to 11. now the control will come back to
the initialization part here we have the
new value for i that is 11 now 11 will
be checked against the condition is 11
less than or equal to 10
no right so the condition here fails
now the loop is terminated the control
will exit the loop so this is how the
for loop works
now let us also consider another example
for follow for a better understanding
so in this particular program we are
going to
print the sum of n numbers
so in that particular n numbers we will
be having even numbers and odd numbers
for example consider that you have
provided the number as 5. so the numbers
in between 0 to 5 or 1 to 5 are 1 2 3 4
and 5. so the 4 is even number and apart
from 4 everything else are odd numbers
so odd numbers are the numbers which are
divisible by 1 or itself so now the sum
of odd numbers is 1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 3
is 6 6 plus 5 is 11 so that's how you
print the sum of odd numbers and the sum
of even numbers that is only four so
that's how the loop works here you have
the condition if else condition and out
of that if else condition you have the
for loop so this particular loop should
be running until a given number that
will be given by you so that's how the
program works now let's quickly execute
this program and see the output so there
you go the program got successfully
executed and now it's asking for an
input let's check out five itself now
you can see we have another program on
my screen which is basically based on
the same for loop so here we have the
for loop we will be providing an input
which is num and inside that we have
another condition that is the if else
loop so basically if loop is dedicated
to find out the even numbers and l slope
is dedicated to find out the odd numbers
now the whole motto of this particular
program is to find the sum of even
numbers and the sum of odd numbers
between
0 to the input number which you provide
for example consider if we provide the
number 5 as the input then in between 0
to 5 we have odd numbers and even
numbers so the even numbers are 2 and 4
and the odd numbers are 1 3 and 5. so
basically what happens here is we are
going to add up the numbers so the sum
of even numbers that is 2 and 4 s 6 and
sum of odd numbers that is 5 plus three
is eight eight plus one is nine so
that's how it should work now let's
quickly try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
program got successfully executed and
now it's asking for an input now let's
enter five itself and see the output
so there you go the sum of even numbers
up to 5 is 6 and the sum of odd numbers
up to 5 is 9. so this is how the program
works
now apart from for loop we also have
another way to declare the same for loop
so that particular type of for loop is
called as the enhanced for loop or in
some cases it's also called as advanced
for loop let's see how the for loop is
declared in a different way so instead
of using the typical for loop which has
the initialization state then the
condition then the pre-increment or
post-increment or decrement kind of
operations we simply have declared the
for and inside that we have end arr
which is the name of the variable of
array type and inside that we have the
array so our array consists of 10
numbers followed from 1 to 10 and now
this particular loop will execute for 10
times or until all the values in the
array are printed so now let's try to
print this so there you go the program
got successfully executed and we have
all our values from 1 to 10 which were
the input or the saved part of the array
now with this let's continue with the
next kind of loop that happens to be the
while loop so you can see an example
based on while loop on my screen so
basically everything is same uh there is
no much of a difference between for loop
and while loop but the only difference
is the keyword instead of 4 we have a
vial over here so
so we have the while condition over here
which says i should be less than or
equal to num divided by 2 and if this
condition is true then the control
should enter into the conditional
statement if
num modulus i is equal to equals to 0
flag is equals to true and prick so
basically the whole motto of this
program is to find out if the given
particular number is a prime number or
not now let's quickly try to run this
program and see the output now you can
see the program got successfully
executed let us try to provide a prime
number and see if the program could
identify it correctly as a prime number
or not there you go the prime number we
provided was 5 and the program
successfully identified it as a prime
number so that's how the while loop
works now let's execute another program
based on while loop but this time we
will place the condition at the end of
the loop so yeah you guessed it right
this is do while loop the only
difference between while loop and do
while loop is that before
the condition is checked in while loop
no statement is executed but it's
completely opposite when it comes to do
while loop first the program or the code
segment will be completely executed
after that the condition will be checked
surprising right let's check out the
practical part
yeah we have our program on my screen
right now so
in the previous program we had the
condition somewhere over here that's the
file condition but here we have the do
statement here so what we are going to
do is we are conveying the compiler or
the interpreter to execute this
particular statement first without
checking the
while condition so this is the only
difference between while loop and do
while loop so we have run the program
successfully and it got executed and we
were supposed to actually print the
values of i from 1 to 20 and they have
printed over here that's how it works
simple right now with this let's
continue with our next topic so
basically the next topic is the next
segment in our tutorial that happens to
be the object oriented programming in
java so before we begin with the object
oriented programming concepts the first
major things that we need to learn are
the classes and objects so the whole
object-oriented programming concept
revolve around these two basic
fundamentals which are the classes and
objects welcome to this tutorial on
objects and classes in java this is a
part of our java tutorial series where
we will be covering everything you need
to know to master java let us look at
what we will cover today first we will
talk about objects and we will implement
two programs on intellij to learn about
objects then we will move on to classes
in java where we will see an advanced
program to learn classes more in depth
so what are objects an object is an
instance of a class let's have a look at
an example in this example animal is a
class and dog is its object the object
dog has states and behaviors we can have
dogs with different breeds sizes and
colors these are considered as the
states of object dog on behavior side
dog has behavior like barking eating and
wagging tail so an object has its own
states and behaviors now let's look at
an example using java code there are
many platforms to run java program so
for this video i'll be using intellij so
let's create a new project let's name it
as project 1 and finish there we go we
have a new project
with we have a class with main and we
have a main function so the code that we
write should always be written in the
main function so let's create a new
class to understand how the object is
used let's name it as student
we need variables so that we can access
the variables of this class so i'm gonna
use
student id with the integer type student
name
and student's age
there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s i created an object
as of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this i'll use id
and give a value similarly i'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a name
now we'll print its value
now we are going to run this program
lets see what output will get
and there it is we have name
that simply learn we have age and we
have id
now let us see an example how we can use
multiple objects for a single class so
let's get started let's create a new
project and i'm gonna name it as
vehicles because i'm gonna use cars and
bikes in this program so i'm gonna use
vehicles as a combined form and yes here
we have a class main and a function main
now i need two classes for this program
so i'm gonna create two classes first
i'm gonna name it as bikes and the
second class i'm gonna name it as cars
so let's create variables for these
classes so in cars first i need string
name
and i need the cost of the car so cost
can be integer as well because i'm going
to use dollar sign in that so i'm going
to use string because of that so same
thing i'm going to do with bikes
now that our classes are created let's
create objects for this class so the
process is same but we are going to use
different names for the object first the
car class and i'm going to name as car1
and yes we have created the first object
now to create the second object
similarly i'm gonna create five objects
of the class cars
and i'm gonna change the name for them
so i created five objects of the same
class so i'm gonna create five objects
of the bikes class as well so bike one
will be a bit longer so i'm gonna use b1
till b5
and i'm gonna name them to from b1 to b5
so now i'm going to assign values to the
variables that i created in classes bike
and cars so first i'm going to go with
cars and let's name it as lamborghini
similarly
car to ferrari
so i am going to use names of the cars
that are very famous and costly so that
anyone over the world can understand
this so let's name car 3
i am going to name it as bugatti
similarly car 4
pagani and car 5
now i'm gonna give names for bikes
i hope everyone will understand the
names that i give
b4
and b5
last one
yamaha
now let's assign the cost for bikes and
cars as well so the procedure is same so
let's do it 130 000
same b2 so b1 goes for harley davidson
b2 for ducati b3 for suzuki b4 for e cos
and b5 for yamaha i am going to assign
values for these values accordingly for
ducati 232 000
dollars
for suzuki 200 000
300 000
and the last one yamaha 500 000.
now similarly i'm going to assign values
for carbon.cost till cart5.cost
two hundred three thousand dollars for
lambo i think i can copy paste these as
well
so
let's
copy paste a lot faster and easier to do
car 2 car 3
car 4 and car 5
we don't need this
uh as for car 2 let's take it as 252
000
and
let's make it 3 million
as per this let's keep it as
1 million
400 000 and lastly
uh let's see is 293 now that we have
assigned all the values for all this now
let's print it and get the value i'm
going to create a very simple program
but a very user friendly program so it's
going to be interesting for you guys so
we are going to ask the users what would
they like either bikes or cars so we
need to give them the options and our
next program will be based on the
options that the users select not the
options we give as the command so let's
do it
let's give the options
one
[Music]
bikes
and two cars
i need to take the value that user gives
for this i'm gonna write this command
so i have not used scanner yet so let's
import
scanner
and let's create an object for scanner
and yes let's get back so the data type
of choice variable is integer that's why
i'm using next int if the data type was
string then i would have used next line
so now that we have choice from the user
let's use this value
if the user chooses the first value that
means bikes so the next thing we display
is we have models and we are going to
give five models for bikes to the user
here i am giving options to the users so
that they can choose easily from number
one to five
now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that i'm gonna ask which one
would you like to choose
to enter the choice i'm going to use one
more variable let's say n so i'm going
to store n
if n is equal to equal to 1 that means
harley davidson then i'm going to show
the cost of harley davidson
this is the syntax to print the value
for the cost or any of the variable that
we use in class
what if the user says second or third or
fourth or fifth so for that we are going
to use else if statements
if n is 2 that means ducati so we have
to show the rate of ducati or the cost
of ducati to the user
now similarly i am going to do for n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 4 and n is
equal to 5.
now i am gonna do for n is equal to four
and lastly n is equal to 5 that is a
last bike yamaha
what if the users put a number that is
not between 1 to 5. so for that i i'm
going to use else statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
1 and 5.
so now we have code for
bikes and the same thing whatever the
user selects that he wants to find the
car so for that we have this the choice
is equal to is equal to 1 so the same
thing we are going to do for choice is
equal to is equal to 2
and the same thing we are going to tell
to user that we have five models
the same names that i gave to variables
i'm going to give this to here
second one ferrari
third book rt
fourth e course
and the last one
posh
now we are going to ask the users their
choice that which number do they want to
choose
now we need one more value so that we
can have it as a variable which can
store the choice of the user so for this
i am going to use c
now if c is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of lamborghini that he puts the choice
as 1 so we are going to display this
message the cost of lamborghini
and we are going to use else if loop to
enter the next values for c from 1 to 5.
if c is equal to is equal to 2 that
means the user wants to know the rate of
ferrari then we are going to show the
cost of the ferrari
same thing if the user enters 3 as the
choice
if user enters 4 as their choice
then we go for e cos
and the last one if user enters the
choice as 5
then we have to display the cost of posh
now what if the user enters none of the
values from 1 to 5 then we have to
display a message
showing that
please enter the value
between
one to five
now remember the first choice that we
wanted from user to enter either bikes
or cars so what if the user do not enter
either one or two so for that we need
one more else function to tell the user
that either enter one or two
and with this we have completed our code
so now let's run this program for this
we need to go to run and then run main
there's a shortcut for it that is shift
plus f10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program let's test this program now
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have five models harley
davidson ducati suzuki pagani and yamaha
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have our result the cost of
harley davidson is one thirty thousand
dollars
so with this we have completed our code
and please feel free to type this code
in your own computer and try out all the
permutation and combinations that you
can with this program so with this let's
move on to classes and understand the
classes and their concept then we'll
have a new program on classes now let's
see what is a class a class is a
blueprint from which objects are created
a class describes state or behavior of
an object in this example dog is a class
the variables in this class are breed
and color the functions or methods of
the class dog are barking hungry and
sleeping we use objects of a class to
use variables and functions of the class
with this let's understand classes with
a simple java code let's create a new
project
next tick the box and let's name it as
automobiles
let the base package be student and yes
we have a class
main now let's create some classes to do
code on
i'll create a new java class as cars
and then i'll create one more class with
the name bikes
and then one more class automobiles
so i'm gonna connect cars and bikes with
automobiles so that we can use that
program in main and see what can we do
with the classes that we create in
automobiles i need some variables
i'll take private double and let's say
fuel and then same thing private double
and then year and let's take one more
private string and brand now let's have
getters and setters for this so these
are used to get the value and set the
value for the variables inside the class
there we go we have the getters and
setters for it now let's go to class
cars
so public class cars extends
automobiles so in it i'm gonna create
one more class
or a constructor
and i'm gonna print a message say a new
car has been created
car has been created now the same thing
i'm gonna do with bikes let's go to
bikes and
i'm gonna use the same thing extends
automobiles this is because i can
inherit all the variables from the
automobiles class
so i created a constructor and i'm gonna
print a message a new bike has been
created
so i have created class cars bikes and
automobiles so let's go to main program
so this is where we should write our
code so i'm gonna start with the code
now it's a very simple code i'm gonna
first i'm gonna create
the variables or the objects of the
class
with private
bikes bike so one is car and one is bike
both are objects for the classes so i'm
going to use this objects
bikes bike is equal to new bike
this is so that my object can function
really well and now i'm gonna run it
it'll take some time to run
and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that i typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes
so i'm going to bikes
so i'm going to create a new method or a
new function
public void kick for bike so i'm going
to print message the bike has been
started with kick
bike has been started
with kick now the same thing i'm gonna
do with cars now how does a car start
with the key so i'm gonna make a
function public
key and inside it i'm gonna print the
same message car has been started with
key i should write void there to give
the return value as wide
so let's print the message
car has been started
with key rotation let's write that as
well so in the main program i'm gonna
use objects to use those functions and
let's see what changes they'll do to our
program
pike dot cake and car dot cake let's run
this
and there we go
first we used to have this two messages
but now these two messages are also
there as well because we invoked those
functions and methods that are there in
class cars and bikes so if i write bike
dot key
or
car dot kick
this won't work
this is because key is not a method of
bike or kick is not a method of car so
that's why i gave private static for the
functions
so if i execute it these are the error
messages that i'll get cannot find the
symbol method kick or method key what is
an abstract class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object-oriented
programming approach and designing a
software
here the programmer tries to hide the
complicated implementation of the code
which makes the software run smoothly
most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it
to do so we use an abstract class or
sometimes an interface based on the
requirement
so abstract class in java is considered
as a template of methods and variables
which are used in a program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly now moving ahead
we will next learn the important
features of abstract classes
so the first one is template the main
reason programmers prefer to use
abstract methods is because they act as
a predefined template
for any future specific class that you
might use
next loose coupling is a procedure where
an internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible
after that we have the code reusability
implementation of the abstract classes
provides the developers with one of the
greatest features that saves time which
is none other than the code reusability
followed by code reusability we have
abstraction as discussed earlier data
abstraction is the process of hiding
certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or interfaces
last but not the least
dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process
the dynamic method resolution is a
mechanism by which a call to an
overridden method is resolved at runtime
this is how java implements runtime
polymorphism
when an overridden method is called by
reference
java determines which version of that
method to execute based on the type of
object it refers to
now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes
alright let us go through the rules one
by one as mentioned below
the first one is
the keyword abstract is mandatory to
declare an abstract class followed by
that the next rule says that abstract
classes cannot be instantiated directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least one abstract method
next to that we have another rule which
says an abstract class includes final
methods
next an abstract class may also include
non-abstract methods
it's not mandatory that an abstract
class should only include abstract
methods
so the last rule says that an abstract
class can include constructors and
static methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in java
so basically there are two different
ways to achieve abstraction in java the
first way is by using abstract classes
and the next one is by using an
interface
now this brings us to our next topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract followed by that
we use the keyword called class
then after that we declare the name of
our class
the name of the class is up to the
user's choice for example i have named
my class as simply learn as shown here
followed by the abstract class we have
the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now i have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
choice as you can see i have used
simplylearn as the name of the method
so this was by using abstract last
method the next one is by using an
interface method
now what exactly is an interface
so interface can be defined as a
boundary between the method and the
class implementing it in java we use
interface to achieve abstraction
in other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program
now we will move ahead and understand
the syntax
to use an interface to achieve
abstraction in java
to declare an interface we use the
keyword call interface followed by that
we declare the name of a class
the class name is up to the user's
choice for example i have named my class
as simply learn as shown
below as discussed earlier interface
acts just as a container that stores
only the signatures of the method we
cannot have a complete method defined
inside it
all we can do is just declare an
interface
now that we have a detailed explanation
about the abstract class and the
interface
let us look into some example programs
based on abstract classes
now we have successfully booted the
eclipse ide now let's create a new
project
so to create a new project just click on
create a project
and this should give you a dialog box
wherein you have to select java project
click next
now let us give a name to our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this process
as you can see the project has been
successfully created and inside the
project simply learn we have the source
file and right clicking the source file
will give us a dropbox where you can
just select new and inside new you can
select a new package
now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the package
moving further let's right click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class
so the name of my class will be employee
let's click on finish to create the
class
now we have our employee class ready
now let's right click on the package and
select new and inside that
let us select another class
and the name of this particular class
will be person
which will act as our abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person
so our first example which is based on
employees where we will have an abstract
class called person
and this person class will be inherited
by the employee class
and gets executed to generate employee
details
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
to execute the program just right click
on the package and go to the run option
and select the first one that is java
application
now you can see we have the employee
named pavitra
and the gender is female and the
employee has logged in successfully so
these are the details which we were
expecting to be presented on the output
console
now moving ahead we shall execute our
next example which will be based on
students
so here
the class student is the abstract class
and three different student classes
namely raju pranita and punit will
inherit the student class and generate
the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that a
student
is being declared using the keyword
abstract and inside that we have an
abstract method which is get rank
and these classes that are
raju pranita and punit will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console
now let us move ahead and try to execute
one last example
based on abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks
here we have an abstract class named
loan and all the banks described in the
program will inherit the loan abstract
class to calculate the rate of interest
on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is loan and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we have the classes andra
bank bank of baroda idbc bank state bank
of india which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output
console so with this we have entered
into our next topic where we understand
the differences between an abstract
class and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword
while we declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface
on the other hand when we declare an
abstract class we use the keyword
abstract
followed by that the second difference
is
when you use an interface the subclasses
basically implement an interface
while on the other hand when you use
abstract classes the subclasses extend
an abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract class
followed by that the third difference is
multiple interfaces can be implemented
but on the other hand only one abstract
class can be extended at one particular
instance
and the final difference between the
both is
interface is capable to support multiple
inheritance
whereas on the other hand abstract
classes are not capable to support
multiple inheritances multiple
inheritance is none other than the
diamond problem which is not supported
in java
now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract class
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in java are
the abstract classes are highly
beneficial in writing shorter codes
the abstract classes avoid code
duplication
they enable code reusability which is a
major advantage
and finally the last advantage is
changes to the internal code
implementation can be done without
affecting the classes
so these were few of the major
advantages of using an abstract class
now moving ahead we shall discuss the
disadvantages of using abstract losses
few of the disadvantages of using an
abstract class in java are
abstraction is expensive as sometimes
you need to handle cases and situations
which are not necessary followed by that
the second disadvantage is
object relational impedance mismatch in
the case of rdbms and the last
disadvantage is object relational
mapping in case of frameworks like
hibernate
so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in java that you need to consider before
using them into your project
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this shield as you can
see variables and methods are defined
inside one class like a capsule
now the question is why do we need
encapsulation the main reasons are first
better control of class attributes and
methods second class attributes can be
made read-only or write-only third it
makes java code very flexible this means
the programmer can change one part of
the code without affecting other parts
apart from these encapsulation is mainly
used to protect data and increase
security of the code as you can see to
protect the data variables must be
private and they can only be accessed
through methods now let's see java code
for encapsulation to understand the
concept better
so now let's create a new project
next
next
and i'm gonna name it as
ncap one
so here we have a main class
we can write the code here so before i
take the code let me create a new class
right click new java class
and i'm gonna name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employee
using employee name id and salary so in
this class let me create variables
first string name
then
[Music]
integer id
and then in salary
so i can easily use these variables in a
main program by creating object of the
class so let me just create the object
employee e is equal to new employee
now i can use e dot id name or salary
anything i need to but this program is
about encapsulation so this is an easy
program we can do but in order to secure
our programs when we have a large number
of program and large number of lines in
a program so we need encapsulation at
that time so that data can be secured
so for that i'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so i
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if i write id
we'll get a red color here so if we go
on it we can see id has private access
so that means we can't use it directly
because of this we need
getters and setters that are normally
methods that are used for these so right
click
generate
and here you can see getters and setters
so just select all of them
and ok
so now we can use these methods instead
of direct using the variables so we can
get in the starting then set then get
and again set so likewise it goes like
this
so now we have set here so
if i want to declare variable and if i
want to put some value inside my
variable so how can i do that
here you can see get id or get salary so
if i go for get id sorry if i go for e
dot set id and i set it as 6
so
this shows no error this means we can
use methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first i'm gonna
set everything
and lastly e dot
set salary let's get it as 30 000
maybe in dollars or maybe in rupees
let's just set it as 30 000 for now
so how i'm gonna print it for this i'm
gonna go to a print statement and then
name
and e dot not set name but this time i'm
gonna go with get name get name is to
return the value of the name that i have
given so in this case that's simply
learn
and next will be id
and e dot get id
and lastly
salary
e dot get salary
so this is a simple program that is used
to define encapsulation we don't use
private variables that becomes a normal
program so when we use encapsulation we
are going to use private every time
whenever we declare variables so that
it's secure and no one can access the
variables directly
so now let's run the program
and there we go we have our result we
have executed the program successfully
and as you can see name simply learn id
6 and salary is 30 000. so i hope you
understood the concept of encapsulation
so the main concept of encapsulation is
all the variables can be accessed
through methods so for this we use
getters and setters that are inbuilt
functions for intellij or netbeans or
eclipse so with this let's move on to
our next program to understand it better
and how we can manipulate these
variables or methods using program
so again let's create a new project
and this time i'm gonna name it as
encapsulation 2 because it's the second
program for encapsulation
and here we have our main program
now this time i'm gonna use an example
of cars so let me just create a new
class and i'm gonna name it as cars
so in this again i'm gonna create three
variables that are private
so first i'm gonna get string name
then private string
price
that means price of the car
and third one
top speed of the car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but i'm gonna explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so i'm gonna
create a constructor for the class cars
and inside i'm gonna give it as
arguments as string name
then string price
and string top speed
and i'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name
this is so that the class can identify
that we are going to give arguments
related to that and the class can return
the values of it so similarly i'm gonna
give it as this dot price
is equal to price
and lastly
this top speed is equal to
top speed
so with this we have completed our
constructor for it now let's have
getters and setters for the same thing
for these three variables
so generate
getter and setter
select all and ok
this is a great feature that we have in
java getters and setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program
we'll write the code here first i'll
create object of the class cars
and inside this i'm gonna give arguments
or inside this i'm gonna give values
that i use in constructor to assign the
values without using any c dot get name
or c dot get price
so my first was name so let me just name
it as bmw
the second thing was price so i'm gonna
give it as thirty thousand dollars
and the third one was top speed so top
speed i'm gonna give it as
200 kilometer per hour so we have
assigned all the values to the variables
and we have created object as well all
in the same line so this is another way
of creating objects or another way of
assigning values to the variables that
are private
so if i try to print these they can be
easily printed
so in the starting name
and c dot
so this time i'm gonna give get name so
it automatically gets the value that i
assign to the variables through getters
and setters
after that price
price c dot price get price
and in the end
top speed
c dot get top speed so if i print this
let's execute it
and there we go we have name bmw price
and even the top speed now if i give
spaces between them
it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more
and here you go
name bmw price 30 000 and top speed 200
kilometer per hour so this is one of our
ways how we can declare variables or
assign values to the variables without
using any getters or setters so in this
method we used only getters to print the
value that we have for variables now how
can we manipulate the variables if we
want to change value of them
now for this again i can do set top
speed or set price let the name be as it
is
so c dot set price
so price i'm gonna set it as
fifty thousand
dollars and c dot set top speed let me
increase it to 250 kilometer per hour
so before printing that i'm so that we
can differentiate which one is new and
which one is old i'm gonna print one
more line
stats after
updation
so now if i print these values i'm just
gonna copy paste it
so now if i print it let's execute it
and here you go
first we have name price and top speed
then stats after updations that means
after we set the value the value gets
overwritten on the variables and now we
have a new price and top speed and all
the details so this is how you can
manipulate variables or values inside
the variables
what is inheritance
there are two other key terms which are
not going to be in this agenda but you
should also
when you get to them make sure you
bundle them together as you're
understanding these structures and
that's the abstract class and the
polymorphism
so what is inheritance
inheritance is an act through which a
new class gets created by acquiring the
variables and methods defined in the
previous parent
class so we look at what is inheritance
we can take an example of say food we
have veggies noodles fruits
where food is the parent and your
veggies your noodles and fruits are all
subclasses of that they're all kind of
children of food
why do we need inheritance
we implement inheritance for a multiple
of reasons like creating a possibility
to add or remove features
to reduce the code length as we reuse
the code
more comfortable to develop and maintain
the project
and so if we start looking at let's say
we have a cell phone we make calls we
have our sms texting our communication
on our phone we have our media we also
had a browser on there because now we
have a smart phone
and we look at that we have our phone
setup and then we have our
full smartphone media call sms and
browser
and we start to kind of link these
instead of making them separate we can
have the call and the text
and then we can have them inherit we can
actually create a media that inherits
their quality so now you can text your
media
now you can use the browser as part of
your call scenario
and i would even add one more example in
here and that is that all programming
languages that are object based are
built on inheritance uh java python c
plus plus so this concept of building an
object and then that object then is
inherited by everything underneath of it
is important to understand even in these
most even as we're looking at more
specific cases
so take a look at the components of
inheritance
and the most important two components in
inheritance the two major components
that are mentioned are parent class or
the super class in the child class or
the sub class
and to see this let's go ahead and
jump into eclipse and take a look at
what the actual code looks like
so the first thing i want to do is go
ahead and add in a new
package
and we're going to go ahead and call
this package
inheritance because that's what we're
working with
oops
give me a default java tutorial in there
inheritance finish
and i started off with the java
tutorials just a um
went in and created a new project and
made sure it was java based
so we have our package inheritance right
here we're going to go and add in a new
class
and we'll go ahead and call this class
machine
now one of the standards when you're
creating classes to capitalize the first
letter so always remember to do that
in some places people like to have the
whole word capitalized it really depends
on who you're working with
but it is kind of if it starts with a
capital letter it's probably a class
and so once we have our inheritance we
have our public class machine
let's go ahead and give it a little bit
underneath there to do something and
we'll start with um
protected
string brand
and so whatever machine we're working
with uh these particular machines are
going to be
um we'll call them it'll be a samsung
free uh
they get some free vocab free marketing
right there for samsung
so samsung machines
and we wanted to do something so let's
go ahead and put a procedure in there
and we'll make it public
voids is not going to return anything
and we'll call this
wash i guess they're all wash machines
there we go there's our brackets a
little trouble finding the bracket on
there and let's just have it during this
we'll just have it do a quick print line
and we'll say um
initiating
cycle
there and then of course our semicolon
on the end
all right so now we have a public class
machine and we're going to get into
where we start working with the actual
inheritance
you can create an object with this
machine we haven't done anything special
to it it's like any other
class you might create in the java
language and we've added in public void
wash a procedure with no return that's
what the void means and it's going to
print out and so let's go ahead and
create another
class in here
new
class
and this one's going to be washing
machine
washing
machine
and
we'll go ahead and hit finish on here
and we come into our washing machine
this opened up a nice new tab for us
and we might have a private
string
model name
and we'll change this to model type
model type equals
so the type of machine is is a top load
washing machine
so we have a samsung as the main type of
machines we're looking at we have top
loader or top loading washing machine
and then we're going to add up here
extends
machine
and so this is the the key code we're
going to look for because we want this
to have the properties of the machine
so this comes in and says whatever's in
machine we now also have in our washing
machine
and then of course if we're going to do
all this we need to actually be able to
run it and if we're going to do that we
want to go ahead and add in the public
static
void main reserved
keywords there and this is just your
standard main
startup you have your string of
arguments
there we
go and of course our bracket
and then in here
we're going to take and create a washing
machine object
and so here's our wash machine
it's of course the type washing machine
and it's going to equal a new
washing machine so we're initiating a
new object in here there we go
and then we want to do something
and if we're going to have it do
something we wanted to go ahead
let's see what happens we have wash
remember our key word up there was
washing machine dot
wash
and where did that come from well if you
go back into machine
here it is public void wash there's the
procedure and it's coming into the
washing machine and this is inherited
that way we don't have to retype that
every time we have a washing machine
this could be washing machine
maybe the next one is
i don't know different kind of washing
machines i'm not an expert on washing
machines
we have to do a wash
and then specific to the washing machine
in here
we also have
the type and so we can come back up here
or brand
so we can come up down here we can go
system
dot print line
wash
machine
dot
brand
plus
a little dash in
there
um plus
and then we're going to go ahead and we
have our wash
machine
dot
model type
that model type we put in there
uh so the brand where does the brand
come from the brand's coming from our
machine we have our protected string
which is going to be samsung
and then we have our washing machine
which has the model type which is a top
load machine and if we go ahead and run
this
after of course we make sure we have
that semicolon in on the end there
we come up there we'll see initiating
cycle initiating cycle is printed out
from machine and then the samsung top
load washing machine is the second
printout line here
and so when we have our wash print out
here also the wash machine wash
is initiating cycle and then we have
that's where that printout comes from
we can go back up here to machine you
can see right here initiating cycle
and then we flip back over to the
washing machine we print out washing
machine dot brand
which is the machine class and then wash
machine dot model type which is
underneath the washing machine
so let's go over all that let's take a
look and see what we're talking about
here
so we saw in the code the extends
keyword
the term extends is a pretty defined
keyword in java that allows you to
create a new child class by deriving the
variables and methods from the parent
class to reduce code links and improve
the performance
and we see that right up here in our
public class washing machine extends
machine
so the next key thing to talk about is
access modifiers
and i kind of breezed over them when i
put together the code but we'll dig in
there a little deeper
we talk about axis modifiers there's
four different words you really need to
know that's default
public protected and private
and i'm going to tell you right now
default equals public
so what is default default access
modifier is set implicitly whenever you
declare a class without a specific
access modifier by default the access of
a class or method when declared without
a specific access modifier becomes
available to any other method or class
within the same package
and in java the default is public
so public a certain class can be
declared as public by using the keyword
public any class or method when declared
as public becomes available to any class
or method declared in the same package
but if a different method or class needs
it it should be imported
and then we have protected a certain
class is declared protected by using the
keyword protected
this provides access to the methods and
variables of the protected class only to
the rightful subclasses and protects the
data from any other classes which are
not related
and then private a certain class is
declared protected by using the keyword
private
this provides the ultimate protection to
the data members and the methods of the
private class this procedure is
implemented by class to encapsulate the
method and members
so
we'll take a little we're actually going
to do a different example in here but i
do like this underneath the washing
machine
you can see right here we have put in
private a private string
what this means is that only washing
machine can access that private string
where if you have protected the children
can access it
so a protected screen if you're
underneath a machine up here we have
protected
so that when i create the washing
machine and extend machine
i can still access it but if i create a
sub
class of washing machine and i mark it
as private that subclass is not going to
be able to access it and so it has to do
with what layers of accessing
think of this as a big team project
you create something do you really want
that to cascade down to the next class
or who do you want to have access to
that
let's go a little deeper to really bring
this home because it's really important
to understand this terminology
let's go ahead and start a new class
here and we're just going to call this
particular class
summation
and
go ahead and create that finish
and so our summation class is going to
be pretty
simple in here
we'll go ahead and do
public
so anything but he can access it just
remember here's our public on there
and then we'll just do a
anti-jerks that's what it's going to
return as an integer
we're going to call it add
and we're going to put integer x comma
integer y
and
then we'll just return x plus y so real
simple we're just adding two numbers
here's our two inputs they both have to
be integers and we're gonna return an
integer and it'll be the summation of
the two so real simple class right there
and if we're going to have a summation
then let's go ahead and create a new
class we'll call this one child
and in our new child class
we're going to go ahead and keep this
simple and we're just going to have our
public static main
we're going to have our summation a
equals new summation
and then system out print line a dot add
100 plus 200.
pretty straightforward everything's
public in here
oops okay
there's our running and we see that
answer is 300.
so this is public if you remember
quickly we're talking about public
and so when we use a public keyword any
class or method when declared as public
becomes available to any class or method
declared in the same package
but if in a different method or class
needs it it should be imported
so here we go it's that's our public
setup it's just open to everybody well
everybody that's under the package
inheritance so whoever's using that
package can now use the this particular
child
and let's go ahead and add a new class
in and this time we're going to do a
parent class
i'll just put that right in there
and we come in with our parent class you
can see right here the parent class
itself is public but what we want to do
underneath the parent class is we want
to create a protected
void because we're not returning
anything and print so we're going to do
the print there
and this protected print let's go and
put our brackets in there and we'll do
just a simple uh print line hello world
and once we have the
print hello world we want to go ahead
and add a child class to this
and let's see we already well we had the
child class when it took it out a second
ago so we'll go ahead and put that back
in here's our child class
and before this child of class we wanted
to go ahead and extend the parent
so inheritance there's our extend on
there oops let me type that
all right extends parent so now the
child class is part of the parent class
and we'll go ahead and put our main in
there so that it will run it and execute
it and we'll create our child x
equals new
child class
let me go ahead and assign our variable
x and initiate it and then we'll do just
the print and see what happens here so
here's our print statement
and we'll go ahead and run this and
compile our child on there
when it comes in there you see it says
print hello world and so the parent
has marked this as protected so it's
protected from
objects that are not inheriting it but
the child can still access that
information and print it on there
so here's protected this provides access
to methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not
related
and a lot of programming that's usually
where you end up is doing a lot of stuff
that is
underneath your parent
that is protected you either make them
public or protected a lot of people are
sloppy and just make them public but
most of stuff you want to make sure it's
protected and then we finally have our
private and i'm going to go back here to
our child and we're going to
run this
and it's going to come up and say
proceed with launch errors in
setup and then it's going to give us an
exception thread main
compilation error the method print from
the type parent is not visible
and that's because unless you actually
initiate the parent
you're not going to see this code
because it's private it's only private
to the public to the parent class so
even if i extend it in child
it will not be available and that again
protects it that means it's something
that you don't want to inherit and
cascade down because maybe it is a piece
of code that is going to be changed and
so you don't want all the children to
crash every time you make a change to it
so with private this provides the
ultimate protection to the data members
in the methods of the private class
this procedure is implemented by class
to encapsulate the methods and members
so very important we have private and we
have protected and we have public the
more access you want other pieces of the
software code to have and other
programmers they have the more public
you want to make it and of course the
default is public
now one of the common workarounds for
this because you only have protected
data but you still want it to be used by
the subclasses
is to create what they call like a get
or a and we'll do it up here
we'll go ahead and do a
private
integer x equals five
and then instead of
on your inheritance instead of having it
uh
call it from
the child we might have a get thing or a
get get thing
we might have a public
you can return an integer
and we might have it say get x
and this simply just return x
and what this means is that
we have something simple like this where
it just does return x i can go back into
my child here
and instead of print x we'll do
x dot
get x
and we'll go ahead and print this out
or you know something simple with that
we'll go ahead and do a uh
system print line on this
and when we run this
you'll see it come up it's going to
recompile
and we get our five
what's happening here is now i've
created underneath the parent
private information you don't know
what's going on with it it's protected
you might have a procedure that's
protected in this case we had the print
procedure and then we access it from the
public and this could have easily have
been instead of
maybe we'll just call it
public
void
public print
kind of a goofy way of doing the code
there we go and then it could go in here
and access our
print
and so we can actually still access this
print variable up here by wrapping it in
kind of a get or a
public function
this allows us to protect whatever code
is going on in the parent class so it
can't be messed up it can't be accessed
indirectly it has to go through the
right processes and so when we get to
the child on here
the child can then still has the public
processes but all the other information
isn't is protected and is private it's
really important to remember that
private right there
this brings us to super keyword
and we talk about the super keyword a
super keyword eliminates the confusion
between parent class method and sub
class method super keyword is
implemented to access a method or
constructor that is defined in the
parent class
so back in eclipse we'll go under parent
and we'll take this we're gonna
take the private out of there so now we
have an integer five
and we'll go ahead and just remove the
print because we're not gonna do that in
the parent
um oops and the public
there we go
and so let's create a parent that just
has one piece of information it has an
integer x equals 5.
and then we're going to go to the child
and let's go ahead and add in here
integer
x equals 10.
and these are by default they're public
we haven't set anything on here telling
it what it is
and so what i'd like to do is we'd like
to go ahead and create
a
oops one more thing there we go
create a procedure here
and we'll just call this void capital
print
this is going to be a system out print
line and this is what i want you to
notice is we're going to print out x
and super x
so we have the child class x and we have
the parent class super x
and if we come down here
and we do x
dot print
don't forget my semicolon
add a couple spaces in here to make it
uh look nicer when we print it and we'll
go ahead and run this
and you can see that the child class
prints 10 and the parent class is 5. and
so this way you can actually store
different information depending on what
it is you're working on and what you're
doing and that's where this super comes
in you can see right here where the
super
underneath the class
and the print module
now you can't just put it in down here
under print
let me explore what that looks like if i
just take this and i go ahead and
highlight it
and let's say i wanted to just instead
of doing x print
it's going to come up right here right
off the bat you see the super dot x i
can do x dot super dot x
and it's still going to give me an error
right here it has to be underneath a
procedure in the actual class and not
under the main
this brings us to types of inheritance
and there's four main types
we have single inheritance which we've
already pretty much looked at but we'll
go back over
we have multi-level inheritance we have
hierarchical inheritance and hybrid
inheritance
let's go ahead and just start with the
single inheritance single inheritance
consists of one parent class and one
child class here child class inherits
parent class methods and data members
and let's go ahead and create a new
class up here just to change it up and
keep an interesting new
class and we'll call this one student
and under the student
then we'll have a simple setup we'll
just do an enrolled and i'll say
enrolled in simply learn there we go so
there's our
class student
and then we'll create another class
we'll do it as a because we have our
student or base student
and then we'll call this one
new
class
and we'll call this one
computers there we go so here's a rolled
finish
and for computers let's go ahead and put
in a print line here
and we'll put down
studying
computers
and we want to go ahead and do the
extends extends
student so it's a student studying
computer subclass computers
and this should all look familiar
because we've been doing this for
you know a lot of the other setups this
is your basic inheritance
and we'll change that from enrolled to
studies
and then let's go ahead and put a main
in here so we can actually run it
and we have our p enrolled which comes
from our
parent class and our p studies which
comes from the
child or the
one inheritance hit the extends for
student
and let's go ahead and run that there we
go run
and you can say enrolled in simply learn
studying computers
and then we can go on to the next setup
and this is where we look at multi-level
inheritance there's also a parent child
inheritance relation but the difference
is the child class is inherited by
another child class
this is the basic structure of most
programming languages right here you
have an object you have all the
different things under the object and it
gets all the way down to whether it's an
array you're working with whether even a
class is a sub child that goes all the
way up to the object and we can simply
do that in our code in eclipse
and we'll just go ahead and add a new
class in there we'll call this one
java there we go
oops
java
and under java we want to go ahead and
oh create some of the similar stuff and
then i want to go back to my student
i took out the main and student just
because i don't want it to run the main
in there
and in here we're going to have system
out
we have instead of studying computers
focus
on java which is what we're doing right
now
and maybe we'll call this classroom and
then we can come down here we have our p
equals new computers well instead of new
computers we want our java
and it's going to be a java object
and we need to put our extends in up
here
extends in this case we came from
computers
so there's our initial thing and then we
have our last print in here
and of course if we run this now we'll
see that it should if i did everything
correctly come up and say enrolled in
simply learn studying computers focus on
java and we have the enrolled which is
the parent to computers
and then we have under computers
well we have student then computers and
then java and so each one of these
classes just cascades all the way down
and this is your multi-level
from your class a to class b to class c
and if you can have multi-level
inheritance we can also have a higher
archaeal inheritance where your
parent-child relationship the only
difference is here multiple child
classes inhere from one parent class
and that is
pretty
we'll do another class here
if you remember correctly we had student
computers
maybe from student we'll have instead of
computers we'll have
project management
project
management so you're studying your idol
and
all your other classes in there for
cascade and for
doing agile programming and in here we
can do that it's just the same as we did
before
we just have a second child coming in
from here and so this would go ahead and
extend extends
extends
student
and of course whatever
subcategory you have one in here for
running this
and so for here we'd have like our void
studies in this case instead of studying
computers
we're studying project management
project
management one of the other wonderful
classes it is taught from the simply
learn team
and we're going to run that and you can
see right here we have computers oops of
course
instead of computers i meant to do
project
management there we go and we have to
also initiate it as a new
and then when we run here we can see
this
we're enrolled in simply learn and we're
studying project management
and then finally there is the
the hybrid the name itself explains it
to us
the hybrid inheritance can be a
combination of any of the three types of
inheritance supported in java
and so maybe we already saw that because
we have
our a and our b if we flip back on over
to
our
eclipse
we have our student our student now has
a computer's
project management so there's our
hierarchy all and then they're mixed
because we also have the java which is
an extension of the computer and so we
have multiple layers there
so one of the issues that comes up with
inheritance in classes is what they call
the diamond problem
and in the diamond problem the java
programming language does not support
multiple inheritance as it ends up with
serious ambiguity
and that is where we have d which
inherits from both b and c
which might both inherit from a
this is the diamond factor because as
you start tracking your supers going up
which one are you actually looking at b
or c or a
and that's why they call this a diamond
problem it comes up more than you would
think you get very complicated
structures and you realize oh i need to
have
both sets of instructions come down to
whatever i'm working on and you can see
where that can become a problem
let us take a look at is a relation and
has a relation
now these i mean they're vocabulary but
they're more of a concept understanding
how things fit together
and so we talk about is a relation when
a class inherits methods and members
from a different class then the
relationship is said to be
is a relation examples orange is a fruit
and oh let's just jump back on over here
and we'll make a
new
class
and we'll call this class customer
so we're going to have our customers
oops
there we go if i can remember how to
type
so we have a class customer and we have
gone ahead and our team in the back went
ahead and prepped this for us
let's just take a quick look though we
got public string name so it's accessed
uh publicly if you leave this out it'll
automatically be public because that's
the default and then we have our
customer and the string which is a name
and a string as a city and then when you
do a customer and you send it the name
in the city it will do this name equals
name and this city equals city we could
have easily done this private we have a
call-in to it to create it so it
wouldn't really matter too much whether
we did it private or
public i would actually be more likely
to do it private
and for this
example we'll go ahead and create
another class and we'll call this thor
we'll have our store class we have
customers and we have a store
and then we'll go ahead and
set up in here and this time we did do a
private we're going to create a list of
customer
customers
and then the store list coming down and
then this customer customers and public
list customers
a quick look at this is we did make this
one private
which is nice because now it can't be
accessed externally except from store
and then store has the public list
customers so we can send it a list of
customers and then it go ahead and
returns the customers from that list
and then we add it to the store it sets
the customers in the store this dot
customers equals customers
one of the reasons we have the error
lines in here is i haven't compiled it
so it doesn't see the customers are part
of our package
and we'll get to that in just a moment
here
and then let's go ahead and create
another class we'll call this is a
relation
since that's what we're working on
and here's our is a relation setup
and we're just going to put this as the
main so you have your main in there
and then we went ahead and prepared
a series of customers
and we'll just call that customer c1
equals a new customer customer c2 equals
a new customer and we're just creating a
list here that's all we're doing
and if we're going to have a list then
we need to go ahead and create a list of
customers
and
we'll just do that with a simple list
and then we got to add those customers
into the list so let's go ahead and do
that
so breaking this down we have a customer
one which is raju
bangalore
shiva hyper bad
sachin mumbai and so on and then we just
created a list of customers a new array
of lists and we add in each of those
customers so now we have a nice list of
all our different customers in here
and then we want to go ahead and
create our
store
and we'll put in store and it'll be a
fruit smoothies franchise i put down
fruit smoothies french
maybe that's not a good abbreviation you
might think it's a french instead of
franchise
there'll be a new store
and then we have our new store which is
um
in this case
we're going to put in that new store
customers and if you remember we went
back here into store let me just flip
back on over there
it's going to take that list of
customers
and put that into this customer so now
the private list is going to equal that
list of customers
and then of course we can come in here
and we do public list it's going to
return that list of customers so we have
public assets here and this store you
can add public at the beginning
we'll go ahead and do that just to make
it clear is it public
is what's going to run on there and
let's go back into our is a relation
and whoops back to store i'm going to go
ahead and just change this to customer
list
so here's our list customer list and
it's going to return
the customers from this selection from
our private variable
as we come into
here we can come down here and we'll go
ahead and
put that in there
we'll do a loop on this we'll have a
list customer and we're going to create
a list of our customers from our fruit
smoothies franchise
and we'll get the customer list from
there
and then for a customer in the um in our
for customer cst in customer
we're gonna go ahead and just print that
name out there
now at this point if you have
an error showing up here under list
and also underneath arraylist depending
on how you did your install
you might have to go ahead and import
those your arraylist from your java
utility not a big deal
and then once we go ahead and we have
this all set up
you'll see here the compiler goes
through and then we have the name of the
customer
the city and then it just lists the
customers going down here
so when we talk about our relationship
of our fruit smoothies franchise and
customers the customers
they are
a relationship directly to the french
smoothies franchise
now the second idea is it has a relation
and let's go ahead and take a look at
that and see how that differs
and we'll go ahead and create a
oh let's see we had customers so let's
do
and we'll call this one um we're doing
with smoothies so we'll have
flavors
um our favorite we'll do favorite
flavors favorite
flavors for class very strange
class and let's see in favorite flavors
we'll go ahead and give it a couple
things to look at we'll have a private
string and a name
and then we'll have a public
string
[Music]
get flavor
there we go and that's just going to
return
return we'll just have that return the
name of the flavor
there we go and then we want to go ahead
and create
one more class and this class will call
has a relation
and i'm hoping you're guessing where
we're going with this let's go and put
some code in here to make it work
and let's go back to our favorite
flavors and put in a constructor so that
we can load the flavors
and then return this name so we can
return the flavors we'll go back into
has a relation
and let's just create a customer we'll
call it custom
our new customer is toby marshall from
mumbai and our favorite flavors are
strawberry banana and peanut butter i
don't know it's a strange concoction
and then we run a print line we're going
to print the customer name from
customers and the flavors get flavor
and so when we're looking at this what i
want you to be aware of is that
neither the flavors
nor the customer are in the same class
they're not it's not an actual
relationship
but they have a relationship because we
have toby who happens to like strawberry
and peanut butter
and if you remember just a quick note we
were looking at the diamond problem
you can create a class that then has
these two subclasses in
and that's how you go around the diamond
problem is you don't inherit but you
create classes inside the class you're
working with
what is polymorphism according to
chemistry the term polymorphism can be
defined as the ability of any element or
compound to exist in multiple
crystalline forms this is called
polymorphism for example if you have the
carbon atom you can come out in
different forms in coal graphite and
diamond
what is polymorphism in java
similarly in the terms of java
programming language polymorphism is
defined as the ability of any object in
clat in a class to perform a particular
task in multiple methods
this is known as polymorphism in java
we're going to open up our eclipse
editor and we're going to do some animal
sounds with cows cats and dogs just kind
of a fun almost kids-like
example of polymorphism
and you can see i already have my
inheritance in here let's go ahead and
create a new
uh package
and we'll call this polymorphism
just to keep it simple
and once we have our polymorphism in
there we're going to go ahead and add a
class in
and if you were doing um
an abstract class we could label as
abstract we're not going to directly
access it and we'll call it animal
sounds maybe we will we'll see how we
load the
program up but we'll call this animal
sounds
and let's create a public it's not going
to return anything but we'll call it
sound
on here and we just want to go ahead and
have it do a
system out print
and with our system out print line we'll
just have it say animals
make
different
sounds
there we go
so yeah it's really simple and
straightforward we're just going to
print something out
and if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and just
a good thing i didn't make it abstract
let's go ahead and just test it out and
see what it looks like and we'll do
oh we'll call it animal main animal
maine
and in here let's go ahead and test out
what we just put together
we'll do our static void main so it's
going to run on here
and we'll create our animal
sounds
we'll call it animal because we don't
know what kind of animal this is we'll
call it new animal
sounds
and we'll just take that animal
um and i like to
put it in capitalize but usually we like
to do this lowercase there we go
and we'll just have our
animal
dot
sound
and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
comes out
we can see here animals make different
sounds okay that's not too exciting
so let's jump in there and let's say we
have
in this case we're going to add in a
couple of different animals
we'll add in a oh let's start with a
cow yeah why not a cow
so we'll have our cow in here we'll go
ahead and click ok
and now we have our cow class but a cow
doesn't just it makes different noises
but it actually
makes us you know a very clear noise so
we'll go ahead and give the cow a sound
and we'll have the cow um say moo moo
and the cow is going to
extend
there's our um
and we'll put in our extends animal
sounds and then i want to go back here
to our animal main
and now we have a class cow so in our
animal main we want to do
cow
cow
equals new
cow
and once we've created the new cow we
also need to go ahead and have the cow
sounds
there we go
and we run this
you can see it comes out here and it
says the cow says moo moo
so if we go back to cal we're just going
to do this real quick
and let's say
we just take this out of here the public
void sound
and then we're going to go into our
animal main and run that
recompiles animals make different sounds
because it doesn't know what sound a cow
makes
so this is really central to
polymorphism is we're taking something
going on in the um
in one setup that we've brought in and
extended from our animal sounds and
we've changed it to the cow says moo moo
and we can also add in multiple animals
in here we'll go ahead and just add in
one more animal we'll call this one
we'll do a dog why not
so here comes in our dog
and of course we want the dog to
actually say something
and we'll have the dog
go bow wow and then we'll go back to our
animal mane we have to create a dog
and we'll say
cow
simply dog dog
uppercase for the class lowercase for
the actual object
and then of course we need the dog
to make a sound so we'll go down here
and go dog dot
sound
and when we run this as you expect the
it's going to compile it there we go
animals making different sounds the cow
says moo moo the dog says bow wow
characteristics of polymorphism the
functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior of a method is dependent on the
data polymorphism is mainly used to
implement inheritance as we saw we did
the extends with the animal sounds
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance it allows same name for a
member of method in a class with
different types
which we'll cover briefly in a minute
polymorphism supports implicit type
conversion
types of polymorphism there are
basically two types of polymorphism that
can be occurred in java programming
language they are mentioned as follows
compile time polymorphism run time
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time thus
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time
in method overloading in java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared
we'll now execute a program based on the
functionality of additional operator in
a different situation and let's flip
back on over to our eclipse
so in here i'm going to go back under
the dog
and let me just highlight this
and we're going to do the same thing so
you see right here it says public void
sound so this is identical public void
sound
but instead of sending uh nothing we're
going to send it a string we're going to
call it angry
now at this point
you should note that what if it's a
happy dog i i would have to add an if
then if the string angry said happy then
we'd print happy or something else but
we're just keeping it simple so we've
entered another sound identical to the
first but we've added string angry to it
and this is going to print out the dog
says growl growl now if we go back to
our animal main
and here's our dog same dog
same sound
but now we're going to add a string in
here
and we put that string in here we'll go
ahead and just call it angry it doesn't
really matter what string you put in
here because we haven't sorted out what
the string means
for now it just says growl growl it's
going to recompile it so remember this
is a polymorphism during compile time
and here we have it the dog says growl
growl the duck says bow wow and then the
angry dog says growl growl so there is
another
thing called operator overloading
operator overloading is not supported in
java the authors of java wanted to keep
the language less complicated
explaining operator overloading it
basically is a way of bundling
operations into the call statement and
user procedures it's so that it looks
like a math on a paper you have a plus
add b plus c kind of thing and it's all
wrapped up in your call to another
statement this just gets confusing it
really isn't necessary so the driver
developers decided not to put it in
there so runtime polymorphism in java
programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage
here the overwriting method gets
resolved in execution
so far we've talked about compile-time
polymorphism as you saw in the program
we just wrote when it's compiling it
does the extend and figures out which
overload method to use on there
in runtime polymorphism method
overriding in java the method
overwriting is a procedure where child
class is allowed to implement a specific
class that is already provided in the
parent class
for run time compilation code or
polymorphism we need to go ahead and
introduce the super key word now from
inheritance you should remember that we
can
look at super from before but we're
going to use it slightly different it's
kind of doing the same thing as when we
did the inheritance but we're doing like
what they call an override during run
time so the term super is predefined
keyword in java that is used to refer
the immediate parent class object or
method defined in the program
in this procedure whenever you create an
instance of subclass then automatically
an instance a parent class is also
created that will be implicitly referred
by the super reference variable
so going back into our animal sounds
let's go in here to dog
and if we add a super
dot
sound
in here this is going to reference
whatever our extend is because we
extends the dog extends animal sounds
and so here's our super dot sound and if
we go ahead and we'll run and compile
this
and you can see here that it comes down
and says the dog says growl growl
because that's what we had it system out
print line to
and then the super animals make
different sounds and so if we go back to
our animal main
this is what it's calling right here
it's going back into sound under the
animal mains and it's printing out or
doing whatever it does here at this
point we usually have it return
something so you can look up whatever
the original class was using
so getting back to
these two setups whether you're using
the super to use a runtime polymorphism
because that's what's happening during
runtime versus compile time polymorphism
during compile time polymorphism method
call is handled by the compiler itself
so the programs maybe take a second more
to compile but it runs faster in the
runtime the method call cannot be
handled by compiler in the execution
stage so if you have any errors it's not
going to show up either during the
compile time we have compile time
polymorphism is less flexible as it
needs handle all method calls in compile
time so you really in runtime
polymorphism your it exhibits higher
flexibility as a method call gets
handled at run time coming in the
execution period for compile time
polymorphism is less
that's what i was just talking about it
compiles it so the compiling takes maybe
a little bit more but if you're
executing the same program over and over
and over again once it's distributed
it's going to run faster
then of course with the runtime
polymorphism the execution period for
runtime polymorphism takes longer it's
just a little bit more usually in most
programs you don't notice this but if
you're executing the same script a
thousand times suddenly that 0.01 second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
thousand iterations uh then with the
compile time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in runtime integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in runtime again that's another
delay because it has to figure out what
it's doing it's not already pre-mapped
out and finally compile time
polymorphism occurs during method
overloading and operator overloading
where runtime polymorphism occurs during
the method overriding
advantages of polymorphism programmers
code can be reused via polymorphism
number one goal of a programmer is to
reuse the code as much as possible so
you're not reinventing the will over and
over again
advantages of polymorphism supports
single variable name for multiple data
types reduces coupling between different
functionalities
and some of the disadvantages of
polymorphism that can come up is that
polymorphism ends up raising performance
issues in real time
you can see where as you're loading all
these different things you might end up
creating loops you didn't know you're
doing polymorphism reduces readability
of the code
sometimes your actual code everything
you look at in java is polymorphism all
based on a primary object so you could
have a very complicated setup and then
it actually is very easy to read when
you actually put your final variable in
there
but when you're going through lines and
lines of code it can be really hard to
figure out what's going on as you loop
through all these different inherited
modules or classes programmers find
polymorphism difficult to implement just
depends the more you use it the easier
it is what exactly is a java collection
a java collection can be generally
defined as a collective unit of objects
in the form of a group
for example a group of numbers of
integer data type etc moving forward we
enter into our next topic where we face
the java collections framework this will
help us understand java collections in a
little more detailed way
a java collection framework represents a
unified architecture for storing and
manipulating
a group of objects its architecture
includes the following
an interface a class and the java
collections api
to understand these in a much better way
we shall now go through the java
collections hierarchy the utility
package java.util contains all the
classes and interfaces that are required
by a collection framework the collection
framework contains an interface named as
an iterable interface which provides the
iterator to iterate through all the
collections
this interface can be extended by the
main collection interface which acts as
a root for the collection framework
all the collections extend this
collection interface thereby extending
the properties of the iterator and the
methods of this interface
the following figure illustrates the
hierarchy of collection framework out of
the complexities we have the interface
and the classes as the major part of the
collections
now let us understand each one of them
at one step at a time as you can see on
the screen we have the iterable class
which is implemented by the collection
class and this particular collection
class is further implemented by list
queue and set and moving ahead we have
the following classes which have
implemented the list queue and set
classes in the list we have array list
linked list vector stack and on the
other hand on the queue we have priority
queue dq and array dq and finally on the
set we have the hash set
lint hash set sorted set reset etc now
moving further we will enter our first
java collection which is none other than
the interface so the first one is an
interface an interface can have methods
and variables but the methods declared
in an interface are by default abstract
that is only the method signature is
available not the body
interfaces specify what a class must do
and not how it must do
it is a blueprint of a class now a java
collection is a foundation to the java
collections framework note that all the
collection interfaces are generic for
example public interface collection is
the syntax for the generics and when we
declare the collection we should use it
to specify the type of object which it
can contain it helps in reducing runtime
errors by type checking the objects at
compile time to keep the number of core
collections interface manageable the
java platform doesn't provide separate
interfaces for each variant of each
collection type if an unsupported
operation is invoked a collection
implementation throws an unsupported
operation exception
now under the collection interface we
have many interfaces that we should use
for data manipulation
a few of the major ones are
set interface list interface dq
interface q interface map interface
sorted set interface
sorted map interface
no worry those are a lot of interfaces
but we will discuss each one of them in
a detailed way along with a practical
example
for a better understanding
so the first one in the docket is the
set interface a set is a collection that
cannot contain any duplicate elements
this interface model is the mathematical
set abstraction and is used to represent
sets such as a deck of cards
the java platform contains three general
purpose set implementations
the hash set tree set and
linked hash set the set interface does
not allow random access to an element in
the collection you can use an iterator
for each loop to traverse elements of a
set
now for a better understanding let us go
through a practical example i have
prepared a code document for all the
programs that i am going to explain to
just save time
you can always have access to it all you
need to do is just ask for it in the
comment section below so you can see on
my screen we have an example for set
interface
in this particular example we are going
to store the elements 21 23 43
53 22 and 65 so let's try to execute
this program and see the output
so you can see the elements stored in
the set interface are 65 21 53 22 and 23
43 so the sorted set is here which is a
21 22 23 43 53 and 65 and the first
element being 21 and the last element
being 65
so this is how the set interface
practically works now let's move ahead
into our next type of interface which is
none other than the list interface so
what exactly is a list interface the
list interface is an ordered collection
that can contain duplicate elements you
can access any element from its index
the list is more likely an
array with dynamic length the list is
one of the most used collection types
and array list and linked list are the
implementation classes of the list
interface
the list interface provides useful
methods to add an element at a specific
index to remove and replace elements
based on the index and to get a sub list
using the index
for a better understanding let's check
out an example
so this particular program is based on
list interface so we are going to add in
three names which are david john and
stacy into our list and also we have a
fourth edition
which is stacy again
just to check if the statement is true
it says
list interface also allows duplicate
elements unlike the set interface
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the names
david john and stacy are added into the
list
now let's come back to our program and
remove this comment and try to run again
and check if the fourth element which is
the duplicate of the third stacey
will be added into the list or not so as
you can see the program got successfully
executed and the fourth element which is
stacy the duplication of the first one
got successfully inserted into the list
so this is how the list interface works
now let's move ahead into our next type
of interface which is the queue
interface so what exactly is a queue
interface q is a collection used to hold
multiple elements prior to processing
besides basic collection operations a
queue provides additional insertion
extraction and inspection operations
cues typically but do not necessarily
order elements in the fifo or first in
first out manner
among the exceptions are priority cues
which order elements according to a
supplied comparator
or the elements in natural ordering
whatever the ordering used the head of
the queue is the element that would be
removed by a call to remove or poll in a
first and first out cue
all new elements are inserted at the
tail of the cube
now for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for queue interface
so in this particular queue we are going
to store the names of fruits apple mango
grapes and banana and apple being the
head of the queue and banana being the
tail of the queue
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so we are also going
to count the size of the queue which is
four basically in the first after that
we are going to remove the element
grapes from the queue
so the command is q dot remove the
element name so after that the grapes
element has been removed from our queue
we have the latest size of the queue as
three
now after that we are also going to
check if the element apple is included
in the queue or not
so for that statement yes the element
apple is included in the queue and the
result is true so this is how the queues
work and let's move further and in the
next phase we have the dq interface so
what exactly is a dq interface
so a linear collection that supports
element insertion and removal at both
the ends is called as a dq interface
the name dq is short for double ended
queue and is usually pronounced as dec
most dq implementations place no fixed
limits on the number of elements they
may contain but this interface supports
capacity restricted dqs as well as those
with no fixed size limit this interface
defines methods to access the elements
at both the ends of the dq
methods are provided to insert remove
and examine the element for a better
understanding let's check out an example
so you can see on my screen we have a
program for dq interface so here we are
going to add in some elements into our
dq and then also try to remove the first
element and print the updated dq
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so as you can see
the program got successfully executed
and the elements which we try to push
into the dq are 52 10 and 21
52 is being the first element and the 21
is being the last element so we try to
remove the first element which is the 52
so after that the updated dq is
having two elements which are 10 and 21
so this is how the queues work now let's
move ahead and learn our next type of
interface which is the map interface so
what exactly is a map interface a java
map is an object that maps keys along
with its values a map cannot contain
duplicate keys each key
can map to at most one value
the java platform contains three general
purpose map implementations which are
the hash map tree map and linked hash
map
the basic operations of a map are
contains key contains value size and is
empty for a better understanding let us
check out an example so this particular
example on my screen is an example
for map interface here we are going to
add three elements and map them as one
as cricket two as hockey and three as
archery
now let us execute this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are mapped with their keys and the
element cricket is mapped with the key
one and similarly hockey with k2 and r3
with k3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move further into our next
type of interface which is the sorted
set interface so what exactly is a
sorted set interface so a sorted set is
a set that maintains its elements in
ascending order
several additional operations are
provided to take advantage of the
ordering
sorted sets are usually used for
naturally ordered sets such as
word list and membership roles
for a better understanding let's check
out an example based on sorted set
interface
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for sorted set interface
so here we are going to add in bob sean
and jennifer into our set and we are
going to print the same
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and we have our
elements printed in the sorted set and
you can see the
names are been arranged in the form of
ascending order according to the
alphabets which have started in the
first position so this is exactly how
the sort set interface works
so the last one in the interfaces is the
sorted map interface a map that
maintains its mapping in an ascendant
key order
this is the map analog of sorted set the
certain maps are used for naturally
audit collections of key value pairs
such as dictionaries and telephone
directories
now for a better understanding let's
check out an example based on
map interface or sorted map interface so
you can see the program on my screen is
an example for sorted map interface
so here we're going to add in the
elements john molly
aaron and daisy into the map interface
now along with the names we also have
their aggregates which is 76.5 for john
87.3 for molly and 78.2 for aaron and
for
daisy we have 73.4 now finally we are
going to fetch the data of molly which
is the aggregate of molly now let's try
to execute this program and see the
output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and knowledge
aggregate is 87.3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move ahead into our next topic
which is the java collection classes so
now that we have finished the java
collection interfaces let us have a
quick understanding of java interface
methods so the first method is the add
method the add method is used to add an
object to the collection and next is the
ease anti method
this method returns to true if the
collection contains no elements followed
by that we have the clear method and
this method is used to remove all the
elements from the collection followed by
that we have the remove method this
method is used to remove the given
object from the collection if there are
duplicate values then this method
removes the first occurrence of the
object next to the remove method we have
the size method so the size method is
used to return the number of elements in
the collection so after the size method
we have the stream method
the stream method is used to return a
sequential stream
with this collection as its source so
the next method we have is the two array
method
so the two array method is used to
return an array containing all the
elements in this collection
followed by that we have the hashcode
method this method is used to return the
hashcode value for this collection
next the equals method
the equals method is used to compare the
specified object with the remaining
elements in the collection
followed by that we have the iterator
method so the iterator method is used as
an iterator over the elements of the
particular collection and finally we
have the contains method
so the contains method returns true if a
specified element is existing in the
collection and false if it is not
present so with this we finish the
collection interface and collection
interface methods now we will move ahead
into our next topic which is none other
than the java collection classes so what
exactly is a class a class is a user
defined blueprint or prototype from
which objects are created it represents
a set of properties or methods that are
common to all the objects of one type
now we'll start up with the first one
which is the hash set class so the java
hash set is the basic implementation of
the set interface that is backed up by
the hashmap it makes no guarantee for
the iteration order
of the set and permits null elements as
well
so this class offers constant time
performance for basic operations such as
add remove contains and size assuming
the hash function
disperses the elements properly among
the buckets we can set the initial
capacity and load factor for this
collection
the load factor is a measure of how full
the hashmap is allowed to get before its
capacity is automatically increased
for a better understanding let's go
through an example
so on my screen you can see a program
which is an example for hash set classes
so inside this we are going to store
some names which are the names of the
manufacturers of bikes along with null
values
so we have added in two null values to
just check if it allows two null values
at once
so basically it only should allow one
null value so let's check out how does
it perform
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and the null value
is stored only once that too in the
first
location so this is how the hash set
classes work
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class which is the tree set
class
so a tree set class is a navigable set
implementation
based on a tree map the elements are
ordered using their natural ordering or
by a comparator provided at set creation
time depending on which constructor is
being used this implementation provides
guaranteed log stein cost for the basic
operations such as add remove and
contains
note that the ordering maintained by a
set whether or not an explicit
comparator is provided must be
consistent with equals if it is to
correctly implement the set interface
now to understand in a much better way
let us go through an example now we are
going to add in some numbers into the
tree set using the add method now let's
execute this code and see the output
so you can see the numbers are added
into the tree set and the numbers are
ordered in ascending order
which is 0 18 88 748 983
8476
now let's move further into our next
type of class
which is
the arraylist class
so add a list in java is a resizable
array that is an implementation of list
interface that allows null elements so
in this class we have three types of
arrays which are one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays and
three-dimensional arrays now let's check
out the one-dimensional array
so
a one-dimensional array looks similar to
this where we have the array index
and the element present in the array so
here our indexes are
1 2 3 and 4 and the elements which are
shown here to understand one-dimensional
arrays in a much better way let's go
through a sample program
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for one-dimensional
array and we are going to store the
elements 10 20 and 30 into my array a
so you can see the program has been
successfully executed and the elements
have been added into my one dimensional
array
moving further we will discuss the
two-dimensional arrays the
two-dimensional arrays are completely
similar to one-dimensional array but the
only difference is the index numbers
earlier we had index number but now we
have index numbers
now using these index numbers we can
represent the elements in a matrix form
so to understand this in a much better
way let's go through a sample code
so you can see this particular program
in my screen is an example for
two-dimensional arrays so here we are
going to add in elements one two three
and four in the matrix form and we are
going to use two for loops to print that
now let's execute this program and see
the output so you can see we have the
elements 1 2 3 and 4 and the elements
are printed in the matrix form
at the array index location 0 0 we have
1 0 1 we have 2 and 1 0 we have three
and one one we have four so this is how
the two dimensional arrays work and
finally let's deal with the third type
of array which is the multi-dimensional
or three-dimensional array
so you can see the three-dimensional
array is completely similar or a little
bit similar to the two-dimensional array
but the only difference is we have a
third vector here
so next up we have the linked list
linked list also come under java
collection classes
there are three types of linked lists
which are single linked list doubly
linked list and circular linked list
now let's check out each one of those
so the first one is the single linked
list so you can see in a singly linked
list each memory segment is divided into
two parts so the first half of the
memory location is given for the element
and the second half of the memory
location is dedicated for the address so
this particular address is used to point
to the next element or the next memory
allocation which stores the second
element similarly the third so this is
how the singly linked list works so the
last memory or location is called as
tale and the last address will not store
nothing but null which indicates the end
of the singly linked list
now to understand single linked list in
a much better way let's try to execute a
sample program
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for singly linked list now
we are going to add in the elements one
two three and four in the form of a
singly linked list now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are 1 2 3 and 4. now let's move further
and try to learn the next type of linked
list which is the doubly linked list so
the doubly linked list is completely
similar to that of the singly linked
list but the only difference is we have
two address locations so the first
address location of the head stores null
and the last address location of the
tail stores null which
indicate the start and end of the doubly
linked list respectively
so here in the second memory location
you have two addresses so the first
address points to the previous element
and the next address points to the next
element so to understand doubly linked
list in a much better way let's try to
execute a sample program
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for doubly linked
list and we have the node which has the
data and previous address next address
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output and the elements that
we are going to store in this particular
doubly linked list are one two three
four and five
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the notes are
one two three and four and five
so this is how the w link lists work and
now let's check out the third type of
linked list which is the circular linked
list so there are similarities between
the previous linked list and the
circular linked list
so the circular linked list makes it
circular based on the last address
location
so this particular address location
points to the first element back again
so this is how it becomes a circular
linked list so to understand this in a
much better way let's check out an
example for it so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for circular linked list
now let's try to execute this and see
the output
so you can see we have successfully
included one two three four five six and
seven and eight into our circular linked
list and they are printed on the screen
so this is how the circular linked list
work so moving further we will try to
understand the next type of classes in
java collections which is the hashmap
class so hash table is based on the
implementation of map interface
this implementation provides all the
optional
map operations and permits null values
and the null key hash map class is
roughly equivalent to hash table except
that it is unsynchronized and permits
null this class makes no guarantee for
the order of the map now for a better
understanding let's go through a sample
program
so this particular
program on my screen is an example for
hashmap class so here we are trying to
load the data which is the name of the
manufacturer and their bike so let's
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and we have the
manufacturer and they are made bikes now
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class in java collection
which is the tree map class so the tree
map is based on navigable map
implementation the map is sorted
according to the natural ordering of its
case or by a comparator provided at map
creation time depending on the
constructor used
now let's check out an example for
better understanding
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for tree map class
so we have the role numbers and the
names of students here now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so the program got successfully executed
and the result has been printed on the
output console
so we have the roll numbers of the
students and their names amber
james wallet and reynolds along with
their respective ids
so now with this we complete the java
collections classes now we move into our
next topic which is the collection api
algorithms
so the first one is sorting sorting does
the job of ascending at descending
numbers based on the algorithm written
by the user for a simple example we
shall consider the bubble sort algorithm
for this one so you can see on my screen
we have an example for bubble sort
algorithm so we have the elements 289 39
48 6 28 1 2 and 33 which are ordered in
an orderly manner let's try to execute
this program and order them
so you can see added before bubble sort
is 289 38 48 similarly 33 and after the
bubble sort we have the sorted array
which is 1 2 6 28 33 39 48 and 289 so
this is how the bubble sort works now
let's move further and understand the
next type of api
which is the shuffling algorithm so the
shuffling algorithms are designed to
destroy the current arrangements they
are employed on creating randomness in
the list so for a better understanding
let's check out an example so you can
see the program written on my screen is
an example for shuffle algorithm so we
have an array which has the elements
completely sorted in ascending order
which is 10 to 100.
now when we run the shuffle algorithm
these elements will be completely
shuffled according to a random order now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
elements which were in an ascending
order are now completely in this order
so this is how the shuffling algorithm
works now let's move further and
understand the next type of algorithm
which is the searching algorithm
searching algorithm is employed to
search an element in the list or array
based on the type of searching mechanism
used now for example let's use the
binary search
now you can see a program on my screen
which is an example for binary search so
we have the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5 in
our array now what we are going to do is
search for the element or the key
element 2 in our array using the binary
search algorithm
now let's execute this program and see
the output now you can see the program
got successfully executed and the output
says the element which you're looking
for is found in the index location 1
so this is how the binary search
algorithm works now let's move further
and understand the next type of
algorithm which is the composition
algorithm so the definition says the
frequency and disjoint algorithms test
some aspect of composition of one or
more collections so the frequency counts
the number of times the specified
element occurs in the specified
collection so the disjoint determines
whether two collections are disjoint
that is whether they contain no element
in common or not now to understand it in
a much better way let's go through an
example so you can see on my screen
there is an example for composition
now let's run this program and see the
output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and
the elements are completely disjoint now
moving further we will enter into our
next topic which is based on the
benefits of
java collections so there are various
benefits of java collections out of
those the major benefits are software or
code reusability so the java collections
enable code reusability to save time
followed by that the ease of designing
apis so the next two is of designing
apis we have the simplicity in learning
and using apis and finally increased
speed in programming so these were the
major benefits of java collections what
is an exception
so an exception is defined as an event
that arises due to an unexpected input
or logical failure in the program
this may not be considered merely as an
error but it surely does impact the
normal functioning of the program
segment
now these types of exceptions are
resolved by the most efficient mechanism
called exception handling
exception handling is not any rocket
science but a simple mechanism that
drives the compiler to the next
statement by making the compiler
understand that the input obtained or
the malfunction that arise is just an
unexpected or an unnecessary event which
can be ignored by sending the user with
a relevant message about the exception
arrows
for a better understanding let us go
through a small example
so as you can see on our screen we have
typed in a program so according to this
program we are going to access a file
called data.txt
from the c drive so this particular
data.txt is not really existing in the c
drive so when we run this program we
will face an exception that says file is
not found so let's try to run this
program and see
so as expected so when we run this
program we get that this particular file
what you're looking for which is
data.txt is not found
or in other words it is not present in
the specified location so this is how
the exceptions work in java
now followed by this we will move ahead
into our next topic where we will
understand the meaning of an error
so what exactly is an error
so here we are trying to learn about the
error just to eliminate the ambiguity
between an exception and an error also
further we will discuss the major
differences between them but now let us
go through the term error first
unlike an exception an error poses a
serious potential threat to the program
or sometimes it is even capable enough
to collapse an entire software
so basically an error is occurred due to
syntax error or some logical error while
coding
so we have a sound understanding of an
exception and an error now let us move
further and learn the differences
between the both
error versus exception
so some of the major differences between
an error and an exception are an error
is classified under unchecked type
whereas on the other hand an exception
is classified under both checked and
unchecked
the next difference is if a program
encounters an error then it turns out to
be completely irrecoverable until the
error is resolved whereas in the case of
an exception
if the program encounters an exception
then the program is easily recoverable
followed by that the third difference is
an error belongs to the package called
java.lang.error
on the other hand an exception belongs
to the class java.lang.exception
the fourth difference says that an error
can be encountered only during the
program's run time whereas on the other
hand an exception can be expected both
during the run time as well as the
compile time
finally we will mention an example for
both an error and an exception
we can consider the input and output
error as an example for error and on the
other hand we can consider divide by
zero exception as an example for
exception
so with the differences discussed we
will now move ahead and have a look at
the exception hierarchy in java
the hierarchy of errors and exceptions
is really simple
there is one root class called the
throwable
now the throwable class is basically
inherited from object which comes from
the superior route called java.lang
now the throwable class is inherited by
two child classes which are none other
than the error and an exception
further an error is inherited by
different types of errors for example
jvm or java virtual machine error memory
error
and also in some cases some of the
errors are caused by the incompatibility
of the ide or the framework which are
you are using
next up is the exception
now the exception is inherited by few
more exceptions which are mentioned as
below the exceptions can be
input output exception sql exception
class not found exception runtime
exception and many more further the
runtime exception is inherited by some
more
which are the automatic exception
number format exception etc
now that we have a good understanding of
the exception hierarchy let us move
ahead and check the differences between
checked and unchecked exceptions
so the first one which is the checked
exceptions
these are really simple exceptions and
can be defined as follows
an exception that pops up during the
compile time is called as the checked
exception
it is not serious and is completely
ignorable
followed by the checked exceptions we
have the unchecked exceptions
on the other hand the unchecked
exceptions are defined as an exception
that pops up during the run time is
called as the unchecked exception
it is considered as serious and is
caused by logical errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular example is based on
checked exceptions
so basically we have a text document
called data.txt
in the location documents username users
c drive
so this particular data file has five
lines so we are going to access the
starting three lines of this particular
file and basically when we try to run
this program we will face some of the
major exceptions which are unhandled
exception type input output
and again the same exception
and here
file not sound exception
so these exceptions are errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular code segment here is
trying to read a document from c drive
which is data.txt
so this particular data.txt has five
lines of text so what we are going to do
here is try to type in a for loop and
try to read the first three lines of
this particular document so basically
when we run this program
we will face some of the exceptions
called file not found exception input
output exception and another input
output exception
so we can resolve this particular
program with small modifications to the
program and then if we run this program
then we can find our lines
so the lines in the data.txt file were
hello welcome to simply learn we are an
e-learning company our certification is
recognized by major mncs end role and
upskill
so this particular example was for
checked exceptions
now
we will also go through an example for
unchecked exceptions to learn it in a
much better way
so this particular example is based on
unchecked exceptions this particular
program is really simple we have an
integer type array and inside that we
have 10 elements which are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 and 10.
so what we're going to do is we're going
to access the 11th element of the array
which is not really present so this
should throw an exception
so array index out of bond exception is
one of the example for unchecked
exceptions
so with this we will move ahead into our
next topic
now we know what exactly are checked and
unchecked exceptions moving further we
will slowly dive into the process of
exception handling in the process of
exception handling we have five major
keywords
so we will learn each one of them as
follows
so the first one is try keyword
the try keyword is used to specify the
exception block
in a program when you specifically type
the exception that you might expect to
face in your program then you describe
it using the keyword try
followed by that the solution for that
exception will be defined in the catch
block so the cache block is used to
specify the solution
finally
the finally is a keyword which has the
executable code which is completely
mandatory for a program to execute
followed by finally we have the throw
keyword the throw keyword basically
throws the exception when it is found
during the run time
followed by that we have the throws the
throws keyword is used to declare the
exception so basically this is where you
declare the kind of exception you are
going to expect a new program sometimes
you might
try to type in your user defined
exception or sometimes you might type in
the exception that is default in its way
or in other words it might be system
defined
now that we have a good understanding of
the implementation of the exception
handling in java
let us move further and solve some of
the most frequently faced exceptions in
java
so with this we enter into our seventh
topic which is common exceptions faced
in java
so the first one is the array index
outer bound
so if you try to store a value in an
array or try to access an element in an
array which has an address exceeding the
address maximum location value then this
particular exception is thrown
so to understand this particular
exception let us go through a practical
example
so as you can see on our screen we have
an array of integer data type so we are
going to store the values 10 20 30 40
and 50 in five different locations of
the array which is
0 1 2 3 and 4.
now we are going to provide the address
of the required element so during that
process we are going to specify one
location which is more than the maximum
location of the array so here the
maximum location of the array is 4 and
if we try to provide the location 5 then
this program should throw us an
exception so let's try to run this
program and see the output
so as you can see we have our array here
now
the program is requesting us to provide
the address of the element required so
what if we provide five
so now it should throw an exception
so this exception is the array index out
of bound exception now let us try to run
this program again and specify the
proper address
so for this time let's provide 4 and see
if we get the output
so as you can see at the address
location we have the element 50 as we
have defined here
now our program is running perfectly all
right
now let's move ahead into the next type
of exception
which is none other than our
null pointer exception
if you try to perform an operation on a
null value this particular exception is
thrown
so might be a little ambiguous to
understand this particular exception in
a perfect way let us go through a
practical example
so here on your screen you can see that
we have a program and inside the program
we have a string called sdr
which stores a text called simply
followed by that we have another
string type which stores a null value
which is abc as you can see abc is
equals to null now here we are going to
access the value of abc so here the
string abc has a null value and we are
trying to access it so this particular
code segment should throw an exception
called null pointer exception
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see it has thrown an
exception called the null pointer
exception so whenever in java if you try
to access the null values then the null
pointer exception is strong
followed by this we have the next type
of the common exception
which is the number format
if you try to store a value with wrong
formatting then this particular
exception is thrown
now to understand this in a much better
way let us try to execute a sample
program
so here on the screen we have a sample
program where we are trying to cast a
string into integer so this kind of
operation should throw an exception
so as you can see the program has been
successfully compiled and we have our
exception here which says number format
exception
followed by this we have another most
commonly faced exception which is the
arithmetic expression
if you try to divide a number by 0 this
particular exception is thrown
now let us go through a practical
example
now you can see we have a sample program
on our screen where we have two
particular numbers and one is equals to
zero and n two is equals to hundred
so here what we are trying to do is we
are going to divide the number 100 by
which is practically not possible so
when we try to execute this particular
program then we should be getting an
exception that says you cannot divide a
number by zero
so there you have your personalized
message which says the divider cannot be
zero try a different number
so this is how the automatic exceptions
work
so with this we have come to our last
topic which is the best practices to be
followed while working with exceptions
in java
so the first one is use exceptions
conservatively
so exceptions have proven that they can
be costly if used recklessly or
unnecessarily
so it's better if we use boolean values
to indicate successful implementation of
smaller operations for example if you
specify a particular operation and it
successfully gets executed then you can
just notify the user by specifying a
boolean value which can be one or in the
case of failure we can just specify the
number zero
next after that we have the customized
exceptions
it is a very good practice of
customizing your exceptions in the
design time rather than planning them on
the go
so in other words we can consider this
as if you're planning to design a
software then
in that particular stage itself you must
also evaluate the kind of exceptions you
might face on the process of designing
so tomorrow if you completely design a
software and suddenly an exception is
popped in your head then designing or
including that particular exception in
your finished software
might be difficult
so it's better you start planning your
exceptions
followed by that we have exception login
keep track of the exceptions and this
process comes handy as the user
understands why exactly a particular
exception has popped up
followed by that we have early through
and early fail an exception should be
thrown as early as possible and should
be resolved in the same pace
and then we have the closing resources
since exceptions halt the complete
program we must make sure that the
system resources are shut so as to save
the resources
what is jdbc
jdbc is a tool or an application
programming interface that establishes a
connection between standard database and
java application that intends to use
that database
need for jdbc
establishing database connectivity to
execute mysql or sql queries and ddl dml
commands
view and modify data records
and one of the most important things to
look at when we're talking about a jdbc
and probably the most confusing part
where the devil's in the details
is data types in a jdbc
so when we start looking at the data
types and you're setting up your data
you have your sql which is your var
character and your java equivalent
java.language.string and you have your
bit in sql in java it's boolean and sql
is numeric
java.math.bigdecimal
integer int real float float float
so there's no real difference in job
between a real number and a float number
your double is double your binary is a
byte
data java sql date so your date and
java.sql date
and there's also your sql timestamp
java.sql timestamp
array java.sql array reference java
sql.reference structure java.sql
structure
character java.language.string
biginteger long in java
variable binary it's a byte
a clob
and that's character large object and
then the equivalent is java.sql.clob
and then you have your blob in sql
which is a collection of binary data
stored as a single entity and the
equivalent in java is going to be your
javasql.blob
now if you're doing a lot of programming
i would suggest having a cheat sheet
there and then once you're up and
running you'll start to remember most of
these just because out of use
with the jdbc architecture
we're looking at the application then it
goes into the jdbc api so you have your
application your writing your java
database connector api
then that has a manager underneath of it
and then you have your java database
connection drivers and the drivers are
the ones that are transferring that
whether it's an sql server mysql server
the oracle database
or different sources that use a jdbc
connection
jdbc environment setup
so when we talk about the environment
setup we have java and your
environmental setup underneath of that
in setting up a java environment you
have to download the latest jdk set java
to home and set your java path so if
you're just using eclipse for the first
time or whatever ide you're using to
program you want to make sure you have
that all set up and you have the current
jdk in there the java development
package
and then with mysql
setting up mysql environment download
the latest mysql workbench extract the
file run the setup file and that'll get
you set up with your own mysql on your
computer and mysql registers with your
operating system so it's kind of like a
global variable when you start accessing
it and it's designed that way because
normally when you're using an sql or
mysql database it's installed on a
server
so it makes sense that you want it
registered with the operating system so
it's accessed globally
steps to connect your jdbc
step 1 import your packages this
procedure is followed to make sure that
the relevant packages are readily
available for the api
step 2 load and register your driver the
imported drivers needed to be loaded and
registered for establishing a connection
between application and database and if
remember in this case we're doing the
mysql so we make sure our mysql driver
is installed
and step three connecting database after
the first two steps the next stage is to
connect the database this can be done by
a git connection
step four writing a query
so now we're actually starting it into
your scripting here we write in the sql
command or query that we need to execute
if you're not familiar with sql it's
good to have an sql cheat sheet set up
once you start understanding how it's
put together you'll find that it goes
really quick and it's pretty fast to
learn but it is its own query language
and you do need to learn
a number of the main settings in poll
language so you know what you're doing
step five executing query now the query
from the api is executed using execute
query
and we'll actually load that up just as
a string variable when we look at that
you'll see how that fits together
step 6 processing result after step 5
the system basically does two things it
processes an output and retrieves the
values from your query
and then step 7 closing statement the
result set and statement needs to be
closed explicitly
and you'll find there's two closing
statements there is your result set
which is still pulling from the database
and then step eight
which is we need to actually close
closing connection so the last stage is
to disconnect ourselves or the api from
the database so we no longer have that
open connection using resources
so we're going to jump into our java
database connection example
and we're going to do that with what we
call the university database
let's start with a basic overview of
mysql and you can go to dev.mysqv
and you'll see here we can look up more
information they have the download of
the newest version
this is
a full sql database package
and some of these you can actually go in
there and if you're doing a database
management they can spread across up to
usually don't want to go more than five
servers but
it is designed to go up to five servers
kind of set up with terabytes of data in
there
for a developer on the programming side
we usually want to install
something like mysql
locally so on my setup it has no network
connections
it doesn't auto start on the boot up of
the
computer and i have it locked down that
way if i use some kind of simple
password or something like that for one
of my demos it doesn't go anywhere no
one can access it
now another option to mysql is also the
sqlite
and you can go to the sqlite.org read
more about it and download it
it has a couple limitations that you're
not going to see in your regular your
full scale mysql or oracle or sql
but most of it will transfer over and so
for a small project you can actually use
it as the back end for storing your data
you can also
integrate it or upgrade it into my sql
because most of the sql commands are the
same
and when you go into uh the mysql which
is a significant download versus sql
lite
you can certainly go down to downloads
and then there's also
the connectors so
devmysql.com download slash connector
slash j
and i bring this up because it depends
on how you set up eclipse
for your interface and your ide and it
depends on what you need and how exactly
on your setup as far as the connectors
we'll look at that a little bit more
closer
in the mysql it isn't oracle-based so
you'll have to set up an account if you
don't have one you have to log in it's
all free as long as you're not doing
like the enterprise with all the support
and help on it you don't have to pay for
it it's an open source
now once you've installed uh mysql and
if you do sqlite you're not gonna have
these interfaces it'll all be done from
java code
but once you've installed mysql it's
going to add in a terminal window and
then also
the workbench which is just a nice gui
interface for mysql server
and we're not going to do anything with
the workbench you can play with it
certainly
because a lot of times you don't have
the workbench installed on your computer
especially if the mysql
is set up on a different server and
you're remote accessing it especially
like if you're in the classroom or
something like that they probably have
sent you your login information so you
can get into the shell quick note though
is if you do your own mysql just note
that i kept this as a local host you can
actually see it down here root local
host
no outward connections and that's just
to protect my computer once you start
opening those you have to be aware of
your passwords and since i'm doing demos
i want to keep my passwords really
simple so that's not the focus of the
programming
i had to log out and relog back in
so once you've gone in there you should
have this a lot of times your interface
might be web-based if it's a remote
mysql connection you're working with and
it'll prompt you for your username and
password
in this case mine is on my computer it
automatically has me login as admin so i
have full admin rights
and then we always like to start by at
least i do is show
databases and these are the current
databases on here
they have some different information on
them that is part of the basic setup and
some examples like sakila
and world are both example databases
that automatically load with mysql
for this example we're going to create a
database
and it's going to be university we'll do
capital there university
don't forget our semicolon
and
time you can see how long it took 0.69
seconds and of course if we go show
databases
you'll see now that there is a
university in there
and we want to go ahead and use
university
that means that whatever we do any
commands that we have in here for tables
or whatever are now going to be going
into the university database
so now our database has changed
let's go ahead and zoom in
let's see here we go set okay
a little bit more so we get a nice big
print so you can see what i'm doing a
little bit better
there we go
all right so we're going to go ahead and
create our table
and this has all been prepared so i
don't have to go through and redo it all
the time
you'll see here we're going to do
a create a table engineering student
and then we have
student id is an integer not null
department variable character 25 long
first name
last name pass out year
university rank primary key
in creating this uh note a couple things
first we created a table engineering
students and we've gone ahead and
created the fields as part of the crate
set up here
and the things i want you to note is
that we have our integer so our student
id is an integer our department is a
variable character and is 25 long
and the reason i say that that is really
important is when we flip back on over
here if you remember from our
there we go
if you remember from our data types
here's our variable character and in
java language that's a string
a string
doesn't say hey it's only 25 long and so
you've got to be a little careful when
you're pushing and pulling this data
especially when you're writing the data
from java into the sql that you check
for that length of that string
and then the integer is of course an
integer and of course your other data
types you can see how they follow suit
but with variable character be very
aware of that that that is a designated
25 characters long
and we're going to go ahead and insert
some data in here
here we go we'll go ahead and insert
into
engineering students values
and this is going to be the student id
and it's also the primary key so keep in
mind that that is a
unique value in there and then we have
cse computer science engineering koran
2018 1272. so there's our
pass out year 2018
and ranked um
i guess number 1272
i'm not sure where the um oh that's the
university ranking there we go
and then we have some prepared data
which i just went ahead and pasted in so
we have a whole bunch of individuals in
our database now
and we'll i mean it's the same line over
and over again insert into engineering
students values and then you have your
list of values
and we can see that by doing a simple
select
we'll do what's the star so it's going
to select everything one of our hot
characters
if you're not familiar with um sql get a
setup on there and look it over
and you can also
download a cheat sheet from somewhere
with all the different commands in there
i myself do a lot of
consulting and so i'm always jumping
around from one platform to another
if you're doing that kind of work it's
more important to understand the
limitations and the advantages of
different systems and then you have your
cheat sheets for putting together stuff
really quickly when you need it
and you can see here the data we just
put in there there's our student ids
department first name last name
pass out year
and university rank
we'll go ahead and do one query in here
real quick we're gonna we already did
one query we're gonna do two queries uh
we did select star from engineering and
then we're gonna go ahead and select
student id department first name last
name so you can actually choose what you
select instead of doing the asterisks
um where student id equals 10202
and when we go ahead and execute that in
here
oops
there we go
you'll see that it returns the one
individual with that student id here
so let's take this back into our eclipse
because we're doing the setup so you
have your my sequel server set up or you
did sql lite with a little bit different
setup going on there and let's flip on
over and see what's going on with
eclipse
so in eclipse we're going to go in new
uh we'll start a new project
and we'll call this jdbc
it's our jdbc project whoops
select a wizard
i forgot where i was going on there it's
a java wizard we're looking for this
project java project
there we go and we're going to call this
there now we're in the right spot
uh jd
bc package that way everything will be
bundled in there in the same package and
finish it
create all right so you can see right
here we have our new jdbc package we're
working with
now at this point there's a lot going on
as far as your options
if you set this up for doing database
management which i did not and i'm going
to show you the two different ways you
can go under
windows and under preferences
and in this list you'll see
database management and then you can
just go in there and set it up this way
and it'll pull in that information for
your sql connections
now if you did not and you downloaded
the mysql
it does have an option to download the
java connex which would put it into
wherever you installed that at which is
default under your c drive program files
now on mine uh i didn't i downloaded the
connection separately
and there's two different ways we can go
under project and under the build
project
give that a moment to come up
oops i mean properties there we go the
project properties and the java build
path
this same window can be accessed by
right clicking on your
package we're working on and then we can
go down to properties and you'll see the
same window opens up
and we're going to go under java build
path
we're going under libraries so these are
libraries we want to include in our
setup and then i click on our module
path and at this point you'll see add
external jars here
now again if you haven't already preset
up any clips you can just add jars and
it will be in the jar library so there's
different possibilities there but i did
a download so i'm going to go add
external jars
and i happen to keep mine on my d volume
under my sql
and you'll see my sql connector java and
this is
mysql 8.0
and i just go in here
oops there we go i just go ahead and
open this up and you'll see right here
it has my connector java
once i set that in it's now added those
packages and there's hundreds of actual
subfiles in there and it's all set to go
and i can apply and close this window
and now i'm ready to go ahead and start
writing my script and start building a
program in here
and let's go ahead and go under source
new i'm going to put in a new class in
here and we'll just go call it jdbc
same as the package i'm going to finish
that
and we're set up with a new class in
here
and once we've got this set the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and import
all of our java setup in here so we have
the java connection and now we want to
go ahead and import it
and when we look at this
we can see we have our
connection and remember two of these
have to be closed explicitly and that's
your connection
uh and when you create the statement
you have your driver manager uh so when
it goes in there that's the piece that
connects to actually does the connection
to the
database the drivers that convert
everything and the code in there so you
have your connection to the database you
have the code that converts it
you have your result so you're going to
get a result off of your query
then you have your exception so if you
have an error throws or something like
that that's where that's going and of
course the actual statement that you're
going to send to the sql server
and of course we want our java to be
able to actually run so we'll put our
main in there public static void main
and it's going to throw the sql
exception uh so you'll see right here
that's what we're working with and
there's our javasql sql exception on
there
so the first thing we're going to need
on our setup let's put that in here it's
going to be our connection information
we need to know the username and i'm
just going to call it string unname
equals in this case i created a user
richard underscore simply learn
and then i created a password my
password remember this is a local host
so you probably don't want to have a
simple password like that but mike this
whole database is locked down on just
this computer there's no outside network
access or anything like that to get in
here
and then of course this is a separate
user so it's not even my admin or root
user
and then we go ahead and put a query
right here in this case we'll start with
our most basic query if you remember we
already did that on our at the very
beginning select star from engineering
students
and we're going to use that query in our
code to start off with
and then another really common thing
when you're setting this up
is that we also want to test it and see
hey did we import our package correctly
is it set up correctly so remember we
came in and we
imported our my sql connector jar file
in the code we would just want to make
sure it's working correctly and that's
what this is it says try class for name
and then it has our com.
driver saying hey do we have the driver
for this that's all that's doing
and if not then it's going to print an
error so we can find out why it doesn't
have that driver
uh and then next we want to actually
start getting into our actual code and
uh in here
we're going to do a try because whenever
you do any kind of major connection you
want to make sure
that
you're looking for your errors you're
not going to miss on anything and we're
going to do a catch
and so we're looking for any kind of sql
exception error
and for this demo we'll just do
you know print it out so i'm oops wrong
spot
goes into the catch section there we go
uh so we'll print it out over down here
as far as the error on there and it's an
xql exception so still looking for the
code which we haven't put in here
yet and this is really where the the
magic really starts to happen because we
have our um
connection
and
there we go
and you'll see that the connection is
that's all this is right here here's our
connection up here
and
we pop it down here we have a connection
we'll just call it con
do one end so keep it uniform
there we go
and this is going to go to the driver uh
so in other words right here we're going
to need a
the driver manager and that's where we
imported here and it says get connection
because that's part of the driver
manager
and we have our url
let's see and we of course forgot to put
the url in up above so let's go ahead
and go back there and put that in
and the url comes out as a jdbc mysql
that is registered with my computer so
my computer has when it's running the
mysql
this is the localhost
in this case we called it university
that's where this comes from
and that's all part of your mysql setup
if you're working with a remote database
you'd want to get this information from
the remote whoever set the database up
so that you have this particular line of
where to call
and so we go back down here we have our
connection it's all set up on here the
next thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead
and
create our statement
and this initializes it so we have a
statement called statement
but this statement is going to be based
on our
driver manager which is then connected
to the connection so these are all
connected to each other and this
generates the format it needs
for when we actually send our inquiry
remember here's our query right here so
we're going to send select star from
engineering students for right now
we haven't put that part in we're just
creating the class or initiating the
instance so that we can do that
and then once we've initiated the
instance here let's go down here
we need to go ahead and generate a
result and so we have our result set
again that comes up here from what we
brought in
we're storing the data coming in or
storing the pipeline to bring it in
we're just going to call that result and
then we have this is generated from our
statement here's our statement so this
is all like linked together here's our
execute query which is part of the
statement and here's the actual query
which is coming that we put together the
select star from engineering students
and then finally we want to actually do
something with our information uh so
we'll do is we'll just loop through it
while
and here's our result
set that we just generated so wall
result
dot
next
and this just generates a boolean so it
says hey there's still another result
coming in so we need to go ahead and get
that next result
then we'll go ahead and create a
and we'll take that string university
data and then
we're going to loop through the
different results
there we go
integer and then there we go university
data
and we want to tag on the end of it
result dot get string i
so what's going on here there we just
did a bunch of things
we are going through each row
result.next each row of data that comes
off of the database until this returns
null there's no next result coming in
there and then we come in there we look
at the result the one we're looking at
is the current one so it goes through i
forget how many we put in there about 20
goes you know row 20 zero row one row
two row three row four
and then on each of these rows
we have a string it's an array of
strings
and we're going to get that string and
it returns i so this is get string of
column i
so we have row and column
and really important it is programming
to really understand rows and columns
because that's so central to most of the
data processing going on
and then finally we want to go ahead and
see our results so let's print them out
we'll put in our nice print statement
system out print line university data so
this is going to print each row as it
goes through it and then i'll reset the
row again to an empty string and then
i'll add each of the columns to that row
for my result and then we'll print the
next row out
and now that we have a complete code
let's go ahead and go up here hit the
run button
it's going to compile it runs it out and
we can see down here
let me just get my double mouse we can
get a better view
here's our different
your id comes up
with their i forget what the actual
setup was but the cse the name the date
the ranking
all that prints out one row at a time
and that's what we're doing here of
course if you're processing the data
differently you might be loading this
into a
user interface this might be generating
other information you might be doing
statistics with it
but you can see
how it's set up in here as far as
pulling the data into the java format
and then running it from there
just so we can get a quick glimpse of
where this goes let's go back up here
and we're going to flip back and forth
between a couple different screens so
let me do that
uh and here if you remember we did
select star from engineering students
and there's the same thing up here that
we got down here this is our mysql
server interface and this is the
interface we built in java
and from here we also did this
particular selection select student id
department first name last name pass out
your university rank from engineering
students where student id is
and we got the single row on here
and this is kind of interesting because
i switched something in the code here
where this could cause a problem it
won't on this one
let me go ahead and paste this in here
and we'll run and compile this one
and you see it comes out with the single
user
so the danger of this particular code
is that i went ahead and hard coded in a
loop for i
equals one to six
and so this one we pulled it just
happened to be that we did selected six
different columns in here so you gotta
be a little careful when you're coding
in here what are you polling and where
is it going
you can see if i take out oh let's do
we'll just remove the student id
and we're going to run that without the
student id
we compile it there we go and it gives
us a bunch of errors because it doesn't
see the we're short a column down here
so when it gets down to this code down
here
under the while statement
and it goes hey where's number six well
there's no number six and so we get a
lot of errors on that
and you can see where our queries uh let
me just go back up here and paste
another query in there we go
and we'll run this one and what we're
looking at is we're going to go ahead
and do the same columns
and
we'll just leave this as a star to make
it easy so we're going to select all
columns
from engineering students where the
passout year is 2018.
just do a copy of that one
and we'll run that
it recompiles
and you can see here's all the 2018
on here if you look at the dates so
they're all 2018
and that's the same as our
query directly into the sql server if i
do the same thing on here
you'll see they're exactly the same
and just because we're having fun let's
flip this back over here and we'll do
one more
sql server
and let's do in this one
let's see let's just take this whole
thing out here
and in this one we're going to pull in
all the departments but i want the
minimal university ranking as the
highest from engineering students that
way we can get an order of the rankings
on here and we'll go ahead and run this
and there we go there's our minimal one
so this one hit the lowest ranking on
there or closest to number one
and we can do that in here and get the
same result uh there's karan karen is
awesome uh ranking number 96
and you saw these other people that are
ranked way below koran so that's this
guy must be super smart
so that concludes our jdbc example
university database where we took a
quick look at my sql server or you can
do sqlite and some basic queries you can
put in there and how that works
what exactly is a servlet
now imagine you are searching for some
information on the internet
you open your local browser and start
typing it
this question from you to the internet
is called as request
so further this request is sent to the
cloud or in technical terms your browser
sends your request to the respective
server responsible for storing for that
particular information and helps you
with it when requested now the server
gets triggered with your request and in
written it helps you back with the
information you have requested for
this answer from the server is called
the response
so this is how the request and response
work in a server for this process to
happen so smoothly and effectively we
need a servlet digging a little deep
into the server we find the component
responsible for such an effective job it
is called the servlet container that
holds java based web application and a
set of individual components called as
servlets
now we are close to our answer so this
particular java based component takes
care of web request and response to sum
it up with the form of a definition
we can define it as follows
a servlet is a java program that runs on
the java enabled web server or
application server they are used to
handle the request obtained from the web
server process the request produce the
response and then send a response back
to the web server now hoping that it was
a clear explanation can we move ahead
with the next topic
so the next topic we have is
so how does the servlet work in reality
or more practically or in depth what's
the life cycle of a servlet
so the life cycle of a servlet in real
time has the following stages
these stages are the ones that a java
servlet actually follows in real life to
get our work done so the stages are in
it service
and
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete and finally
destroy now let us understand each one
of them in a bit more detail
the first one is the init process
the init method is called only once it
is called only when the servlet is
created and not for all the requests
afterwards so it is used for the
one-time initializations just as with
the init method of applets
the servlet is normally created when a
user first invokes a url corresponding
to the servlet but you can also specify
the servlet is loaded when the server
first started when a user invokes a
servlet a single instance of each
servlet gets created with each user
request resulting in a new thread that
is handed over to the do get or do post
as appropriate
the init method simply creates or load
some data that will be used throughout
the lifecycle of a servlet followed by
the init method we have the service
method
so what is service method
surface method is the main method to
perform the actual task the servlet
container that is the web server calls
the service method to handle request
from the client or the browser and to
write the formatted response back to the
client each time the server receives a
request from the servlet the server
spawns a new thread and calls service
the service method checks the http
service type and accordingly performs
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete etc and calls do get do
post do put do delete etc methods as
appropriate
the service method is called by the
container and service method invokes do
get do post do put and do delete etc
methods as appropriate so you have
nothing to do with service method but
you overwrite either with do get do post
and other types depending on what type
of request you receive from the client
so this is how the init and service
methods work now digging a little deeper
we have the do get do post do delete and
do put methods
so first we will discuss about do get
method so what exactly does a doget
method do a get request results from a
normal request from a url or an html
form that has no method specified and it
should be hardly by do get method
followed by do get we have
do post
a do post request results from a html
form that specifies list post as the
method and it should be handled by do
post method similar to to get and do
post the do put and do delete options
are usually used to update and delete
the data
when asked by the client
so to sum up these do get do post do put
do delete we can consider them as crud
operations so do get basically gets the
information what you're looking for do
post method usually post the information
or provides you with the response from
the server and followed by that we have
the do put which is usually used to
update the data which is present on your
server and finally delete which is used
to delete an existing data on your
server so these can be considered as
crud operations
and finally we arrive at the last method
which is the destroy method
the destroy method is called only once
at the end of the life cycle of a
servlet this method gives your servlet a
chance to close database connections
halt background threats write cookie
list or hit accounts to the disk and
performs other such cleanup activities
so with this we finish up the lifecycle
of a servlet now we shall understand its
architecture
the architecture of a servlet can be
understood by reverse engineering the
life cycle of a servlet so this is how
the servlet execution takes place when a
client or a browser makes a request to
the web browser
so the servlet architecture includes the
following first one servlet interface
to write a servlet we need to implement
the servlet interface servlet interface
can be implemented directly or
indirectly by extending generic servlet
or http servlet class
followed by that the next part is
request handling methods as we have
discussed before there are mainly three
methods defined in servlet interface
which are init
service and destroy and inside service
we have do put do post do get and do
delete methods the first time a servlet
is invoked the init method is called it
is called only once during the life
cycle of a servlet so we can put all
your initialization code here the
service method is used for handling the
client request as the client request
reaches the container it creates a
thread of servlet object and request and
response object are also created
these request and response objects are
then passed as parameter to the service
method which then processes the client
request the service method in turn calls
the do doget do post methods if the user
has extended the class from http servlet
and lastly the creation of instances
this is based on the load of the servlet
so with this we have finished the
architecture of servlet moving further
we shall quickly discuss the features of
servlets and then enter into the
practical mode
so the following are the features of
java servlets the first feature is java
servlets are portable in nature as i
have mentioned above the servlets use
java as programming language
since java is a platform independent
programming language the same holds true
for servlets for example you can create
a servlet on windows operating system
that uses glassfish as a web server and
then later run it on any operating
system like unix linux and apache tomcat
web server this feature makes tablet
portable and this is the main advantage
of servlet over cgi we shall discuss all
the differences of cgi versus servlet in
the next section for now we will discuss
the features followed by the first
feature we will now enter into the
second feature which says java servlets
are efficient and scalable once a server
is deployed and loaded onto a web server
it can instantly start fulfilling the
request of the clients
the web server invokes servlet using
lightweight thread so multiple client
requests can be fulfilled by servlet at
the same time using the multi-threading
feature of java
compared to cgi where the server has to
initiate a new process for every client
request the servlet is truly efficient
and scalable the next and the final
feature of java servlets is they are
robust and highly secure by inheriting
the top features of java such as garbage
collector exception handling java
security manager etc the servlet is less
prone to memory management issues and
memory leaks
this makes the development of web
applications and servlets secure and
less error prone so these were the
important features of java servlets now
let us enter the practical mode
so we are in the practical mode right
now there were two parts in the
practical mode the first one was to set
up the environment for java servlets and
the second one was to execute a basic
program
so this document has the following steps
to follow
that is the prerequisites before
executing a java servlet program
so we have these prerequisites where we
have to set up java home
and java path followed by that we need
to set up the home and path for jre
which is the java runtime environment
and finally catalina home and path so
catalina home and path is nothing but
the tomcat server home and path
now we will set up these things by using
the environment variables now i'm using
a windows operating system so i'll be
using the control panel to enter the
environment variables
there you go you have edit environment
variables
so inside that just select environment
variables
and inside this you can see that i have
already set up the environment variables
for catalina home java home and jre home
so now let us just select java home and
edit it so that we can see how did i set
it
so you can see i have named the variable
name as java home and inside the
variable value i have a location so this
location is nothing but the java jdk
location in my local system
now followed by that we have jre home so
similar to java whom we have set up the
jre home as variable name is equals to
jre home and the variable value is the
location of gre folder in my local
system so i have my jre folder in my
local system at c drive program files
java jre
and similarly the catalina home
which is inside my program files apache
software foundation and tomcat 8.5
so similarly we'll also check up the
path variables so inside system
variables you can see the path just
edited so then you can see the path
variable set for java
jre and tomcat
now just select ok
ok and finally another okay
now your prerequisites have been set up
so this is how you set them so in case
if you have doubts about the tomcat
version to download then i'll help you
with that just open google
and type in tomcat download
so now you have entered apache tomcat
official site and since i'm using a
windows operating system i'll be
selecting the 32-bit or 64-bit windows
service installer version
and after this gets downloaded you need
to set up the home and path variables
for catalina server
so once after the environment is set up
you need to follow four stages to create
a servlet program which are creating a
dynamic web project create a servlet add
servlet api jar file and run the servlet
so to create a dynamic web project you
need to select new and inside that you
have
the option of other just select other
and inside that you'll be finding
web
so select web and inside that you need
to select the dynamic web project and
select next
so you just need to name to your dynamic
web project so i'll be
naming a server
then select next
and inside that you have a source folder
and now you can select finish
now there you go java eclipse will ask
you for opening this particular in java
ee perspective
then just select open perspective
now basically java will set up
everything you need here
and there you go you can see
server folder here which has already set
up everything you need
now what you need to do is set up a new
servlet
so right click this
and select new
and inside that you can see the option
of servlet just select it
now you can see a new dialog box and
here you need to set up the class name
for now let's just type in hello and go
to next
now again next
and in here you have a lot of options
so for now we are just executing a basic
program so let's just select do get
method
now let's just finish it
and there you go your servlet has been
ready so this is the basic template
created by eclipse for you now next we
need to add in the build path so for
that you need to right click the server
and then
select build path
and here configure build path
from here you can add the external
library select the external libraries
option
and you can see i have the tomcat
libraries here just select all and open
and that's how you add all the required
libraries of tomcat server now apply and
close
now the last step is to execute the
project now just to save time i have
already typed in the program
which is over here
now let's try to execute this
this program will just provide us a
simple output which is none other than
hello world
now the server i have choose this tomcat
server
let's finish it
so there you go the message has been
displayed successfully hello welcome to
simply learn
now we'll move ahead with our next topic
now that we are done with the
environment setup and the basic example
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using java servlets
so first we will discuss the advantages
the following are the advantages of
using servlets in java
servlet is convenient in modifying
regular html
we can write the servlet code into jsp
so let's include the feature of
multi-threading of java
we can make use of exception handling of
java
servlets have a separate layer for
business logic in the application and
finally it is easy for developers to
show and process the information so
these were the advantages of using
servlets in java moving ahead we will
discuss the disadvantages of using
servlets
so following are the disadvantages of
using servlets in java
designing a servlet is considered as a
little complicated so let's often slow
down the application
business logic of servlet is difficult
to understand we need a jre which is the
java runtime environment on the server
to run our servlets and finally the data
connectivity is a little complicated so
these were the major disadvantages of
using servlets in java moving ahead we
will understand cgi
why are we learning cgi because even cgi
is similar to servlets and it also does
the web interactive job similar to
servlets so thought you should know
about some basics of it so let's
understand its definition and
architecture real quick so the cgi or
common gateway interface is a standard
for writing programs that can interact
through a web server with a client
running on web browser
these programs allow a web developer to
deliver dynamic information usually in
the form of an html via the browser a
cgi program can be written in any
language including java that can be
executed by your web server cgi programs
are commonly used to add search engines
guest book applications database query
engines interactive user forums and
other interactive applications to
websites in very basic terms a cgi
program must interpret the information
sent to it process the information in
the same way and generate response that
will be sent back to the client
most of the input of cgi program is
passed into through environment
variables so with this we will move
ahead into the architecture of common
gateway interface
so you can see the architecture of
common gateway interface is completely
similar to servlet normally the request
is sent in the form of an http request
so this particular http request is
divided amongst the cgi shells and it
will be processed by the cgi shells
based on the program provided and the
response is sent to the user now moving
ahead we shall understand the
differences between the common gateway
interfaces and
the servlet so the first difference is
the common gateway interface scripts are
executable codes written in native
operating system while on the other hand
the servlets are written and run using
the java virtual machine
the next difference is the common
gateway interface performance is
considered to be low compared to
servlets on the other hand servlets are
having high performance compared to
cgi's
the third difference is
for a common gateway interface it is
hard to switch between different
platforms that is the operating system
platforms
when we come into servlets the servers
are considered to be completely platform
independent
followed by that the common gateway
interface scripts are directly executed
so on the other hand servlets are
translated into bytecode because the
servlets are executed using the java
virtual machine and in java virtual
machine whatever the code you transfer
it will be converted into bytecode first
then executed and the last difference is
the common gateway interface is not
portable and on the other hand we have
the java servlets to be completely
portable so these are the major
differences between the common gateway
interface and java servlets now let us
understand the java servlets requests
and responses so first we will deal with
the request phase in request we have
various types the first one is being the
http request the http object is used to
represent the http request to a browser
that the user sends to the web
application thus anything the browser
sends is accessible through the http
request followed by the http request we
have the request parameter the request
parameters are the parameters that are
sent from the web browser along with a
request the request parameters are
typically sent as a part of the url or
as a part of the body of an http request
followed by the request parameter we
have the request header the request
headers are the name value pairs sent by
the browser along with the http request
the request headers contain the
information about the web browser
software being used what type of files
that the web browser can receive etc
followed by the request header we have
the input stream if the browser sends an
http post request request parameters and
other potential data is sent to the
server in the http request body it
doesn't have the request parameters that
is sent in http request body it could be
pretty much as the data like file or
soap request
the next one is a request session the
session object can hold information
about a given user between the request
so if you have set an object into the
session object during one request it
will be available for you to read during
any subsequent request within the same
session time scope followed by the
request session we have the servlet
context the servlet context contains the
metadata related to the application
followed by subreddit context
we will enter the response phase in the
response phase we will deal with the
first one which is the http response the
satp response object is used to
represent the http response to your
request a web application sends back a
response page to the user as a response
to the http request from the browser
sent to your web application
followed by the http response we have
the right html to initiate the process
of sending the html back to the browser
you need to retrieve the print writer
from the http response object
this can be done using the right html
followed by the right html we have the
response header similar to http request
the http response includes headers as
well these are responsible for all the
data written in the response followed by
response header we have content type the
content type header is responsible to
tell the browser about the type of
content you are sending in the return
followed by content type we have the
content length the content length header
is responsible for telling you about the
number of bytes your servlet is sending
you in return followed by content length
we have redirection
redirecting will help you to redirect
yourself to the different web page from
the current one so these were the http
requests and responses in java servlets
now we will enter the next part where we
will deal with the session tracking and
cookies so first we will understand
session tracking session simply means a
particular time of interval session
tracking is a way to maintain state or
data belonging to a user it is also
known as session management and servlets
http protocol is stateless so we need to
maintain state using session tracking
techniques each time the user requests
to the server the server reads the
request as a new request so we need to
maintain the state of a user to
recognize a particular user you can
understand this in a better way by
looking at the picture showed on the
presentation each time you send a
request you will be receiving a response
from the server as well as this
particular request will be recorded as a
state in order to recognize you as a
particular user now after session
tracking we will enter into cookies
cookie is a small piece of information
that is persisted between multiple
client requests a cookie has a name a
single value and optional attributes
such as comment path and domain
qualifiers a maximum age and a version
number by default each request is
considered as a new request in cookie
technique we add a cookie with response
from the servlet so cookie is stored in
cache of a browser after that if the
request is sent by the user the cookie
is added with a request by default thus
we recognize the user as an old user
there are two types of cookies they are
non-persistent cookie and persistent
cooking let's understand non-persistent
cookie first a non-persistent cookie is
valid for a single session only it is
removed each time when the user closes
the browser now let us understand the
persistent cookie the persistent cookie
is valid for multiple sessions it is not
removed each time when the user closes
the browser it is only removed when the
user logs out or signs out from the
browser so before we begin with what
exactly is a java api we will understand
what java is
so basically java consists of two major
components that are java runtime
environment and java development kit
so when we get into java's api we might
want to dig a little deep into java's
development kit
so jdk consists of three more major
components that are the java's compiler
java virtual machine and apis now we
will learn each one of them in a bit
more detailed way so at first we have
the java's compiler
so java compiler can be defined as a
software program that is designed to
convert the high level that is the user
return or user readable code into the
computer readable code that is the
machine level or byte code so this
particular byte code will be transferred
to the next state where we find the jvm
so what is jvm so jvm is an abbreviation
for java's virtual machine so java's
virtual machine is responsible for
processing all the byte codes and
providing an output to the user
next we find our topic for today's
discussion that is the java api
so just like java's virtual machine and
compiler java's apis are the integral
software packages that come with the jdk
the primary intention of api is to
establish communications between
different applications
so on my screen you can see a pictorial
representation of java api's
architecture so at first we have the
java's program on the topmost layer so
this particular segment will be having
the user written program and user
language
followed by that we have the interpreter
javas api and the java's virtual machine
which are responsible for reading and
compiling the java's program
so at the last final level we have the
application hardware which is
responsible for interacting to the
java's program so this is how the java
aps architecture looks like now followed
by this let's dive into the next topic
so in the next topic we find the types
of developers using various types of
apis for different jobs
so at first we have the open developers
next we have the internal developers and
at last we have the partner developers
don't worry we will understand each of
these developers in a bit more detail
and along with some examples for a
better understanding
so at first we have the open developers
so open developers are used by top-end
companies so leading companies provide
access to their apis as open source
through authentication via a unique
secret key to keep track and ensure the
legal usage
so basically what happens here is there
might be some big companies like social
media companies or some other companies
which provide the apf they use for their
applications as open source to the
developers so these open developers get
access to their apis through getting
authentication
so they'll be creating a profile they'll
be providing the research details of
their application like what are they
using that particular api for and other
reasons to use those apis then they get
the unique secret key from the owner of
that api
and that's done just to keep track that
the api provided is not misused
so the open developers majorly include
the b2c teams and some of the major
companies that provide the apis for open
developers are twitter and telnex so one
best example is the twitter where the
twitter provides twitter api for the
twitter developer accounts for using
that for any kind of developing things
or some data science applications and
much more
so followed by the open developers next
we have
the internal developers
so you can consider internal developers
as an organization
so the internal developers belong to a
specific organization and work in a
close environment these apis run with a
high security that can establish
communication between the application
and the application hardware
so only the internal developers that is
the developers belonging to that
particular organization have the access
to that particular api
so this particular type of apis
run on a high security level
so internal developers majorly include
b2c teams b2b teams a to a teams and b2e
teams
so some of the major companies that
provide the internal apis are instagram
google mail and google cloud virtual
machines
next we have the partner apis
so the partner developers are similar or
like internal developers but the only
difference is there is a collaboration
between two or multiple companies for
example consider yourself to be linked
with a different company and you both
wanted to create an application so only
you both can have access to that
particular api that you are using to
create your application
so partner developers majorly use the
b2c teams and the major companies
providing the partner apis are microsoft
and fenextra
so with this we finished the first topic
that was what is api and who exactly
uses it and for what purposes now we
dive into the next segment where we
learn the need for java apis
so why exactly we need java apis
now java apis are used for multiple
reasons but the three most important
reasons for which we use java apis are
to streamline the operations improvise
the businesses and finally create some
powerful applications we will discuss
each one of them in a bit more detail
so the first one is to streamline
operating procedures we have multiple
social media applications like twitter
facebook whatsapp etc followed by that
we have multiple delivery applications
such as amazon flipkart then we have the
fnb such as zomanto swiggy etc so all
these applications are running smooth
and hassle free because of the
significant improvement in the
implementation of java apis by using
java's apis users are provided with
multiple options on the screen so this
kind of approach makes the functionality
very simple and easy to use
followed by this the next important
requirement is
to improvise the business
introducing apis to the public leads
many companies to release private data
to generate new ideas fixing existing
bugs and receive new ways to improvise
operations the twitter developer account
is an example for api that gives
programmers private api keys to access
twitter data and develop applications
followed by that we have the third one
which is to create the powerful
applications online banking has changed
the industry forever and apis offer the
customers ability to manage their
finances digitally with complete
simplicity so this is made possible only
by the use of apis
now followed by this we will dive into
the next topic where we understand the
types of java apis
so basically there are four different
types of apis in java
they are public private partner and
composite we will discuss each one of
these apis in a bit more detail
at first we will deal with the public
api
so what are public apis public means
open so public or open apis are java's
apis that come with the jdk
and they do not have any strict
restrictions about how developers use
them
so followed by the public apis we have
the private apis
so the private or internal apis are
developed for a specific organization
these particular apis will be accessible
through the authentication by only the
employees belonging to that particular
organization
so followed by private apis we have the
partner apis
so similar to private apis even partner
apis are having some authentication
process to use so
the only difference is here instead of
one organization we might have two or
multiple organizations and the employees
belonging to that particular group of
organizations will be able to access the
apis and implement them or use them
followed by partner apis we have the
last one which is the composite api
composite apis are microservices and
developers build them by combining
several service apis now that we have
covered the different types of apis let
us now discuss the categorization of
java apis based on the services that
different varieties of apis in java
provide
so data and api services are another way
to categorize java apis other than the
previous type which is the public
private partner and composite apis are
also classified based on their data
manipulation capabilities and the
variety of services they offer so this
type of categorization has four
different types which are the internal
api services external api services crud
operations and user interface services
we will understand each one of them in a
bit more detail at first we will
understand internal api services
internal api services are developed to
offer organizations services specific to
that particular organizations
these services include only complex data
operations and internal processes
followed by internal api we have the
external api external api are open
source apis that developers integrate
into existing application or website so
internal apis are something similar to
private apis and externals apis are
something similar to
public apis next we have the crud
operations so credit apis provide data
manipulation operations over various
data storage units such as software and
service that is sas and relational
database management systems such as
rdbms using standard data storage unit
connecting tools like database
connectivity that is jdbc etc
next we have the user interface services
user interface service apis are open
source apis that allow developers to
build user interfaces for mobile devices
computers and electronics now let's
examine the rules and protocols that
java apis must follow
so that brings us to api service
protocols
the rules and protocols guide the
different functionalities of java apis
so different apis have different service
protocols let's consider an example for
restful api service protocol as an
example
so for a typical restful api developers
must follow the following rules
for a typical restful api developers
must follow these rules
stateless uniform interface client
server cache layer no worries we will
discuss each one of these protocols in
detail first we will discuss stateless
so what exactly is stateless
so since the restful api follows client
server architecture by default it is
recommended that restful api services to
be stateless all the time
next we have the uniform interface the
entities in a restful api are server and
clients
applications that run on global scale
need uniform client and server interface
through hypertext transfer protocol or
http and uniform resource identifiers
uri will allocate the required resources
next we have the client server
the client server model used in the
restful api should be fault tolerant
both the client and server are expected
to operate independently the change is
made at the client and should not affect
the server and vice versa
next we have the cache including a cache
memory allows the application to record
intermediate responses and run faster in
real time a restful api also includes
the cache memory
and next we have the layer
a restful api is built using layers
layers of api are loosely coupled or
independent from each other each layer
contributes a different level of
hierarchy and also supports
encapsulation
next we will go through some frequently
used
apis so this is the list of most
frequently used apis in real time so we
have web api facebook 4j twitter 4g
android api java advanced imaging java
data objects and you can also see the
acronyms for them in the right column so
some of them have no acronyms and some
of them have acronyms for example we
have android api as google java advanced
imaging as jei data objects as jdo etc
so moving into the next slide we have a
few more apis so we have restful apis
java media frameworks java per system
apis java speech api java 3d java usb
for windows etc and similarly on the
right column we have their acronyms so
for java media frameworks we have jmf
for restful apis we have nothing and
java 3d we have j3d java speech api as
js api and few others so followed by
this we will advance into the next topic
where we will discuss about the
advantages of using java's apis
now using java's apis will help you with
multiple advantages now we will discuss
the most important advantages of using
java's apis
so the first one we have the extensive
sql support apis in java enable a wide
range of sql support services in users
applications through a component-based
interface
next we have applications apis in java
provide effortless access to all of an
application's major software components
and easily deliver services
next we have efficiency
java's apis are highly efficient because
they enable rapid application
development also the data that the
application generates is always
available online
next we have the automation api allows
computers to automatically upload a
download update and delete data
automatically without human interaction
followed by that we have integration
java apis can integrate to any
application and website and provide a
fluidic experience with dynamic data
delivery
followed by that we have scope java's
apis make websites application and
information available to a wide range of
users and audience
followed by that we have customization
java aps enable developers and
businesses to build applications that
personalize user interface and data and
finally we have the adaptability java
aps are highly flexible and adaptable
because they can easily accept feature
updates and change to frameworks and
operating systems
what exactly is java enterprise edition
the java ee stands for java enterprise
edition which was earlier known as j2ee
and is currently known as jarkataka ee
the java enterprise edition provides a
platform for developers with enterprise
features such as distributed computing
and web services
now let's move further and understand
why exactly we needed java enterprise
edition we needed java enterprise
edition for four major reasons to have
powerful api support to reduce
development time to reduce application
complexity and finally to improve the
application performance so followed by
the need for java enterprise edition we
will move ahead and understand the java
enterprise specifications so in the java
enterprise specifications we are going
to discuss the four major specifications
used by enterprise developers
so the first one being the enterprise
specification followed by that we have a
web specification then we have web
server specification and finally some
other miscellaneous specifications we
shall discuss each one of them in detail
firstly we will move ahead with
enterprise specification so in
enterprise specification we have the
first one to discuss that is the context
dependency injection
the context dependency injection
provides a container to inject
dependencies as in swing
next we have java enterprise java bean
the enterprise java bin is a set of
lightweight apis that an object
container possesses in order to provide
transactions remote procedure calls and
concurrency control
followed by java bean we have java
persistent apis so the java persistent
api are the specifications of object
relational mapping between relational
database tables and java classes
next we have the java transaction api
it consists of java interfaces and
annotations to establish interaction
between java transaction support offered
by java enterprise edition the api is in
the abstract from low level detail to
the interfaces are also considered as
low level followed by java transaction
api we have the java servlet
the java servlet specifications define
how you can manage http request either
in a synchronous or asynchronous way
so followed by java transaction api
which is one of the enterprise
specifications we will move ahead into
the java web specifications
so the first one in the java web
specification is the java servlet so
this specification defines how you can
manage the http request either in a
synchronous or asynchronous way it is
low level and other specifications
completely depend on it so followed by
java servlet we have the java web socket
so the java web socket is a computer
communication protocol and this api
provides a set of apis to facilitate web
socket
connections followed by websocket we
have the java server faces
so the java server faces is a service
which helps in building graphical user
interface out of the components so
followed by java server faces we have
the unified expression language the
unified expression language is a simple
language which was designed to
facilitate web application developers so
followed by the web specification now we
will enter the web server specification
out of which we have the first one which
is a restful web service so the java
restful api web service provides
services having representational state
transfer schema
next we have the json processing
java api for json processing is a set of
specifications to manage the information
provided in a json format followed by
json processing we have json binding so
the java api for json binding is a set
of specifications that provide for
binding or parsing a json file into java
classes
next we have the xml binding so xml
binding simply allows for binding of xml
into java objects for example soap is an
xml based protocol to access web
services over http this api allows you
to create soap web services so followed
by the web service specifications of
java enterprise edition we finally enter
into the other miscellaneous
specifications of java enterprise
edition
sort of that the first one is the
validation so the validation package
consists of various interfaces and
annotations for declarative validation
support offered by bean validation api
in java followed by validation we have
the patch applications so the batch
applications provide the means to run
long-running background tasks which
involve large volume of data and which
need to be periodically executed
followed by batch applications we have
java enterprise connector architecture
so the java enterprise edition connector
is a java based technological solution
for connecting java service to
enterprise information system so with
this we will enter into our next step
where we will learn the system
requirements to install java enterprise
edition
so the basic requirements to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system are you should be having the java
virtual machine from the standard six
edition or more followed by that your
local system should be having at least 1
gb of ram capacity
next your system should be having at
least 250 gb rom space available and
finally you should be having the java
development kit installed into your
local system
now next we will understand how to
install java enterprise edition into
your local system
so in short these are the steps you need
to follow to install java enterprise
edition into your local system first you
need to browse into the oracle official
java site then go to java standard
edition development kit followed by that
accept the license terms download the
jdk file run the jdk file as an
administrator in your local system then
set up the java environment i know this
looks a little bit complex but don't
worry i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a much detailed way how to
install java into your local system
please check that to have a better
understanding of how to install and set
up java in your local system
so followed by this we will learn the
differences between the java standard
edition and java enterprise edition
so the first difference between the
standard edition and the enterprise
edition is the standard edition provides
basic functionalities like defining
classes and objects whereas java
enterprise edition mainly focuses on
high-end and corporate type of java
applications
the second difference between the both
is java standard edition comes with only
the standard specifications which will
be used by a beginner and similarly on
the other hand java enterprise edition
comes with some advanced specifications
which support web applications and
servlets
the third difference between the both is
the java standard edition comes with
features like class libraries and
deployment environments whereas the java
enterprise edition has structured
application with the clients business
and enterprise layers
the fourth difference between the both
is
the java standard edition is used for
desktop and mobile application
developments whereas on the other hand
the java enterprise edition is used
mainly for development of web
applications
the fifth difference between the both is
the java standard edition is preferred
and used by beginners and on the other
hand the java enterprise edition is
preferred and used by experts in java
field
the sixth difference between the both is
the java standard edition does not have
authentication whereas on the other hand
there are strict rules and regulations
to be followed when using java
enterprise edition related to
authentication
what is junit
junit is an open source unit testing
framework for java
here the term unit testing framework
comes into consideration
so before moving forth let's check what
is meant by the term unit testing
unit testing as the name suggests is a
way of testing a unit
here a unit refers to the smallest piece
of code that can be fetched out of the
system
it can be a line of code a method or a
class
keep in mind smaller the chunk of code
the better it is if the tested units are
small the tests tend to run faster
providing a better insight into the code
and its performance
unit testing helps in the early
identification of defects
it enables the developers to spend more
time on reading the code rather than
writing it
and a successful code helps in boosting
the confidence of the developer
then coming back to junit the framework
is used by java developers to create and
test their codes
it is used for unit testing of the
source code and junit works on the
approach of testing a small part then
coding that and continuing the same till
the end
junit testing helps developers to
develop more reliable readable and a bug
free code
every time a new code is added
all the test cases have to be
re-executed to make sure that nothing is
broken
there are graphs in junit that show the
progress of the test
the graphs show green when the test runs
smoothly and it turns red when the test
fails
now when we know about junit let's see
the way to download and install that
into our system
before you go on to install junit make
sure you have jdk and eclipse
installed in your computer system
so
let's go on
first open your browser in the browser
type
download junit
in download junit we'll get about junit
in about j unit when we scroll we find
download and install
in download and install
when we go inside that link we will find
two jar files
here let's download these two jar files
when we click on this download button we
will download jar
after the first jar is downloaded let's
go back to that page and download the
second jar file
after both the jar files are downloaded
let's go to the location
here we can see two of our jar files are
downloaded
let's copy these jar files
go to our documents and here in the java
libraries where all the java libraries
are stored let's paste them
after we have pasted these files
we shall open our eclipse
as soon as our eclipse opens we will
first create a project here new then we
shall create a java project
in java project let's name it
junit
installation
click on next
and finish
here
then in this java project
right click on it
and go to the build path option in the
build path option go to configure build
path
here go to the tab libraries
and this side go to add external jars
in add external jars you will get the
location of our two jar files and if you
don't get them you can browse to the
location where you have stored them or
to the location of java libraries
then select these two files and open
them
you will see the two jar files appear
here then click on apply and close
now come back to junit installation that
is a project right click on
it and click on refresh
then right click on the src folder
go to new and create a package
let's name the package to be
junit
install
and click on finish
in this package
create a new class
and we shall name the class
junit
install
and click on finish
now let's create a method over here
in the method we shall type
public void
my
junit
install
and system dot
out
dot print ln
welcome
to my
j unit
welcome to my j unit
testing
now i will add a library over here
library
test
i can see a error
now when i hover over this library
i can see it says import test
so now when i click on it the error is
gone
now we shall run our test and since we
are testing with junit we shall click
here
go on run as junit test
here we shall click on ok
and then we can see in the console it
shows welcome to my junit testing as we
had placed it over here
here on the left side you can see the
junit report
you can see runs one out of one and
there is no or zero errors and same
there are zero failures
so here in the space provided you can
have as many number of tests as many
bunch of code you want and with the help
of junit you can test any particular
part of the code
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the run time
jit or just in time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just in time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java
so the answer for this particular
question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes because java does not
follow any specific rule for the order
of specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if you just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question so what would be
the output of the following code segment
is the sixth question so this might
happen sometimes so basically what
happens is your interviewer will throw a
question at you which has a code segment
so all you need to do is decode that
code in your mind and provide the output
so this would be the code that we will
be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has hundred plus hundred
plus a string which is simply learn and
in the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
hundred plus hundred so what will be the
output of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
one zero zero one zero zero as the
second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
hundred plus hundred plus simply learn
so jvm here understands 100 as an
integer value and the plus symbol as an
addition operator here so followed by
the addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus
hundred so followed by that we have
another plus symbol here so followed by
the plus symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learn similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value
so it considered the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator similarly it
happened with the second plus symbol as
well so that's the reason we had
e-learning one zero zero one zero zero
as the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c and similarly a bank is
associated with person x
that is a bank a bank b and banksy are
associated with a person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x
but the banks do not possess any kind of
ownership over the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented so this question might be a
little confusing but it's true java is
not completely object oriented but
what's the reason yes i'll explain you
why java is not completely object
oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100
object-oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the endfloat double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types
just as we discussed before
java is not 100 object-oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jar files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no
because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motto was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string pool if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there then the jvm will create a new
string that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program then your program might crash so
you can avoid this kind of crash by
using exception handling so basically
you can use try and catch blocks so you
can embed your code inside the try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as special symbol or
zero is provided by the evaluator then
send a message saying wrong input or
divide by zero exception so this kind of
approach will provide an output but this
kind of approach will avoid your program
from crashing so this is how exceptions
are handled in real time so followed by
this we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable
will remain constant throughout the
execution of program so sometimes if you
include a normal variable and provide an
operation on that particular variable
then the value of that particular
variable will change after the execution
of program but when you declare the same
variable using final keyword then no
number of operations or any kind of
manipulations applied onto that variable
will not change the value of that
particular variable so that's the
speciality of final keyword in java so
followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method don't forget to specify the
static keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets oracle has the
following variants for java development
kit so the first one is the jdk standard
edition which is normally used by
beginners and intermediate developers
next after the jdk standard edition we
have the java development kit for
enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition now followed by 21st
question we will dive into the next
question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only
and finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine
so in case if you declare a variable or
a data manipulating method without using
any specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question
that is
can a constructor written a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly he cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable
so the term this keyword is used to
refer to the current class properties
like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain super keyword in java so the
answer for this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyboard
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs edition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name at
so here you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method then which method to be
overloaded that's the confusion right so
should i overload or should i execute
the first add method or the second
method so this completely depends on the
number of parameters you pass if you are
passing two parameters then the first
method will be executed if you are
passing three parameters then the second
method will be executed so this is how
the method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before
the values of the variables or data
manipulating methods will not be changed
when we have used the keyword static in
front of it so the question is can we
overload a static method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method the process
worked through an error reading static
method cannot be referenced so followed
by this we have our next question
so the next question is define
late binding
the answer for this question is binding
is a process of unifying the method call
with the method score segment
late binding happens when the method's
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the run time
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in linked
list than an array
so basically linked list and array are
the java collections or in other words
it's also considered as data structure
so to answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is a
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations
so consider that your memory location
starts from 100 and your array has
10 locations so it's a complete reserved
block of from 100 101 102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array so now
let's have a brief answer on this delete
function is faster in linked list as the
user needs to make a minor update to the
pointer value so that the note can point
to the next successor in the list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly bound state runable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
performed the operation of right
shifting so when you provide a binary
number or binary value then the bits
will be shifted towards the right and
the second symbol or the second operator
which is having three greater than
symbols is used to shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators now followed by
that let's have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage
next is the start stage third is the
stop stage fourth is destroy and finally
we have paint
now the next question is why are
generics used in java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types so followed by this we
have our next question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization serialization is a process
of sending your java code or java
project from one computer system to a
different computer system so basically
if you wanted to execute some kind of
java program from a different location
then you serialize this particular code
to a different location where you
actually want to execute and this
particular process of transferring your
code is called as serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
demon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the demon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in
java so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block off
code in the class when creating the
objects at low time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called so the
answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the
finalized method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is can the keywords this and
super
be used together
so the answer for this question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use so with this
let's continue with the next question in
the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine after the jsp
page is compiled into a servlet
directives are used to set page level
instructions insert data from external
files and specify custom tag libraries
directives are defined between the
following symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive
so include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page the page directive is used
to define specific attributes in the jsp
page like error page and buffer the
taglib directory is used to declare a
custom tag library which is used in the
jsp page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative
discourse of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java
application so the next question is
explain jca in java so the answer for
this question is jca is basically an
abbreviation for java cryptography
architecture
so jca provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third-party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security
so the next question is
explain
jpa in java so the answer for this
question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets so the answer for this
question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using
html followed by that we have the third
type of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula this makes digest more secured
and lastly we have the client
certificate authentication the client
certificate authentication requires that
each client accessing the resource has a
certificate that it sends to
authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol
thanks to our training experts hope you
found this tutorial helpful with that
note we have reached to the end of this
session if you have any queries
regarding this tutorial or if you feel
you have a suggestion for us then please
feel free to drop it down in the comment
section below and our experts team will
be happy to reach you out this is ravi
signing off until next time thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here